la bascule à l'air d'avoir fonctionné
rapidement et facilement
et on va avoir un premier visuel sur les
caméras ça fait plaisir
donc là on à la table de fabiano caruana
contre prête que on va aller voir la
table eu ainsi elle s'allume parce que
bien entendu c'est pas dit
que je réécrivais
atx escobar et parce que là en fait si
on fait la bascule pour les caméras et
qui a aucune cam qui nous intéresse
c'est complexe ce qu'on fait on est
vraiment venu que pour la cam de fuir ou
en vrai
à vrai dire
le bug qui fait bien plaisir pour la
dernière ronde
je vais écrire directement jusqu'à qui
écrire maintenant et table 3
oboya pas la can non plus
roue libre
non l'as cannes 3 qui s'ouvre
donc ça c'est la table de maxime qui est
élevée on va faire un saut sur sa
position en profitait
maxime qui pour la première fois du
tournoi
parfois le temps de la première fois
qu'on a les calmes ne joue pas sur la
table deux oies
il est relégué table 3 et il a cette
position un peu complexe
mais jeu à trois résultats c'est une
position qui doit convenir à maxime
et on a ici la table 1
donc avec avec
eau paris grégory
qui s'est pris la 5 à 4 d'alireza
polytechnique rênes de la création et au
piège aux échecs enfants ils viennent ne
serez pas nouveau en france est ridicule
travailler sur les ratios non mais
arrêtez les gens fassent si vous n'êtes
pas capable de comprendre que c'est
extrêmement difficile d'être top mondial
aux échecs et voulait comparer ça avec
l'école pour déjà
peu importe
rester dans cette illusion que l'école
c'est très difficile et que et que le
sport de haut niveau c'est très facile
et puis et puis et puis ce sera cool en
fait
et puis ce sera très cool
dans mon cas
donc 4 qui est joué ça disent parfois
qu'ils avouent plus de joueurs d'échecs
amélioré beaucoup plus de mecs niveau
égal à karlsson et autres c'est vrai
j'ai faim mais c'est incomparable avec
des examens en fait tu peux pas comparer
le fait de réussir un examen ou de faire
des examens avec des tournois de haut
niveau c'est pas du tout la même chose
c'est vrai que si tout le monde joue aux
échecs et tout leur est dû te faisais du
try hard le niveau serait plus élevé et
ce serait plus difficile
mais c'est incomparable avec avec faire
des examens d'entrée dans des écoles ou
des examens d'école
comme ça donc à
donc donc il a joué à quatre
jouer b3 donc il veut empêcher en fait
de se faire fixer plus tard a parfois eu
[Musique]
b 3
il veut quoi notre ami au part in
la chance qu'un retour max après ce
tournoi écoute ce sera les grands prix
fille de faudra voir qui est qui est
inscrit
encore les amis mais je vous explique
juste pour répondre à dakar le chat je
vous explique juste un truc c'est
complètement différent et vous pouvez
pas comparer quelqu'un qui travaille
trois mois ou six mois
pour ou un an ou deux ans pour des
examens et des gens qui se tape pour
être le meilleur ultime dans un truc qui
font depuis qu'ils ont l'âge de 5 ans en
fait c'est juste incroyable au niveau
qu'ils ont mais c'est comme quand vous
regardez du tennis ou quoi
c'est pas en train de te dire que les
gens
qui sont les meilleurs au tennis dans
leur truc que ce qu'ils font c'est
normal genre continuent à nadal ou
djokovic tu dis pas que c'est des gens
normaux en fait
tu vois que c'est ouf en fait le
ce qu'ils doivent faire tu sens en fait
qu'il ya une présence qu'il ya quelque
chose qui se passe qui sont différents
des autres
tu le sens quoi
c'est que c'est quelque chose en fait
c'est
il ya une intensité ça se voit moins aux
échecs parce que c'est moins visuel
comme sport mais mais il ya une
intensité il ya un truc
sauf que ça dans la société ou en
malaisie nova les jarrets j'arrête jared
ce truc je vous met en émaux tonnes lit
ce qu'est ce qui est utile et inutile
ça va encore être un autre problème on
va mettre le chat en émaux tonnes lie
et ce sera beaucoup mieux comme ça
ce sera beaucoup mieux comme ça donc il
a fait le b3
qu'est ce qu'il va faire résa sur b3
déjà première chose qu'on a envie de
regarder cécile prend
que les blancs reprennent tour prend un
tour prince a généralement on n'a pas
envie parce que ça donne la colonne a
donc ça vaut pas trop le coup de laisser
cette colonne au blanc
normalement après il ya peut-être encore
des choses concrètes qui se passe mais
visuellement c'est parce qu'on a envie
de faire du coup lui l'a pris en d4 pour
le moment ok pourquoi pas
non je pense pas que les blancs soit
tenter de prendre un des six parce que
ça remettrait un petit peu la structure
j'imagine qu'ils vont prendre des cas
plutôt du pion à mon avis peut-être il
veut prendre g3 prendre g3 et jouer
cavale b6
genre si on fait ça tout simplement
pour vous aussi sot prochain est ce
qu'il ya le moindre problème pour les
noirs
[Musique]
est
ce que c'est un problème je vois pas
pourquoi les blancs seraient mieux en
réalité on tape on tape sur b3 on à la
paire de fouilles à les pions c6 qui
empêchent des cinq à la tour qui vient
en 18 on a la structure un petit peu
abîmés mais en réalité le pion f et
bloque le pion eux le pion ces blocs le
pion des les blancs et un duo central
nom va pouvoir facilement mettre les
tours en face on va mettre le fond aussi
ce pur pour taper sur la diagonale
et voilà
il n'y a pas de
de problème
ingérable ici dans la position des noirs
est ce que les blancs peuvent tenter un
truc et agressive de genre céder sur fou
prend prendre de f
or et c'est lors des quarts et les g5
mais bon à vrai dire
ça détruit encore plus la structure
blanche et ça semble pas offrir de plus
value on décale la dame pour éviter de
se prendre un problème colonne f et on
va jouer qui avait b6 au prochain un sap
pas une mauvaise tête j'ai pas
l'impression que les blancs puisse
prendre le dessus d'un truc qu'on peut
essayer c'est fou prend pions prend et
s'éprend avec l'idée de jouer pour
cavaler c4 est un peu le pion des six
faut quand même faire qui a et b ci sont
l'empêchent on va mettre le fond gk tous
réussissent
et on a eu des signaux qui part à tout
moment la position semble assez plate
salers peyrens café alireza
on voit pas du tout comment
comment
un peu m
alireza en danger
je vois pas
traille et raisins en danger ici après
il peut la jouer un mais je leur parle
j'imagine j'ai l'impression qu'il n'a
absolument rien obtenu dans l'ouverture
et il a même pas une position vraiment
tranchantes il préférait avoir un trois
résultats mais c'est la grosse force
d'ali reza c'est à dire qu'il attendait
peut-être une car au calme et il voulait
aller peut-être qu'il a préparé quelque
chose aller le chercher dans la carro
kahn parce que c'est une ouverture
solide est bonne pour faire nul et
alireza qui switch et qui part et qui
part sur sur le 4 5
et sur la berlinoise
c'est ça al'avantage d'avoir un
répertoire large
ça permet de ne pas se faire ciblées et
la alireza mais clairement
cela à profit et côté maxime
côté maxime sajoo
j'ai quasiment envie de dire bonne
chance à ayew
parce que dans ce genre de position
maxime il est extrêmement dangereux
et c'est vrai qu'il est et qu'il a été
obligé d'aller chercher maxime sur une
variante tranchante ue
mais il peut se faire il peut se faire
tranquille peut se faire contrer
le joueur chinois
ou par une sage voilà camille les dég il
est dingue parce qu'il n'a pas la
position qu'ils voulaient il est pas
moins bien avec les blancs mais il n'a
pas la position qu'ils cherchaient
alireza là qui s'approche un vraiment il
avait 95 % de chances de qualification
avant avant la partie je pense qu'il à
98,5 99% de chance
ça devrait aller au bout
et au bout du bout il ya une place aux
candidats à 18 ans à peine
je vois pas trois
comment paris ne va pouvoir presser on
va laisser réfléchir mais
il a pas l'air d'être heureux le joueur
russe
et les russes les russes n'ont ils ont
réussi quand même à m cariat qui n'a
dans les dents les candidats déjà bon
après ils auront soin des peaux qui sera
champion du monde soit soient repêchés
entre guillemets au candidat
mais il aurait pu espérer en mettre un
joueur de plus via ce grand suisse
voir continuer ali reza qui fait la
partie qui doit faire
solide mentalement un joueur français
à
noter au pas il
elle est dans le dur là
il est dans le dur
il n'a pas réussi à obtenir une position
d'attaquant ça le problème
la position s'aplanit et peu c'est
pourrait se diriger petit à petit vers
la nulle il n'y a pas forcément manière
à mettre un bordel sur l'échiquier ici
on obtient des positions plutôt plat toi
ou les pièces risque de se liquider
petit à petit
après il ya quand même une place
éventuelle au grand prix fields pour eau
paris ne faut pas non plus qu'ils
s'envoient complètement en l'air donc
ils pourraient être tentés de
concéder la partie nulle si ses chances
on venait à devenir trop maigre il
risquerait pas 1 5 % de chances de gain
à 90% de chances de défaites 5 % de nul
ce ne serait pas vraiment dans ses
intérêts
et ça ça fait aussi le bonheur d'ali
reza qui du coup peut éventuellement
espérer
une petite nul
qui n'arrangerait pas les deux joueurs
mais qui
par dépit ne le dérangerait pas
forcément complètement grégory
qui a quand même quelque chose à perdre
un petit peu d'argent aux siens 1 op art
in
il et il est classé
2659 c'est pas un joueur qui roulent sur
l'or alors j'ai pas le tableau
précis des prix dans deux tournois mais
mais un petit 10 15 milles bâle
pourrait mettre du beurre dans les
épinards du russe
ou de l'huile d'olive 1 ça ça dépend
appris comment il assaisonne ses
épinards
ça c'est une question question
d'assaisonnement même et s'ils partaient
sur du beurre alors après est-ce que
c'est du beurre doux ou du beurre salé
là encore la question la question reste
entière ça ce sera ce sera à lui de
denfert d'en faire le choix choix qui ne
regarde qui ne le regarde que lui
peut-être peut-être les gens qui vivent
à sous son toit et qui partage sa
cuisine et leurs goûts culinaires mais
sorti de la
sortie de là c'est vrai que que ça peut
être une somme substantielle
pour le joueur russe mais voilà qui
n'est pas un joueur du top niveau et qui
n'a pas
forcément souvent l'occasion de jouer
dans des tournois bien dotée
financièrement impacts qu'ils ne le
veulent pas mais son niveau ne lui
permet pas de recevoir
ces invitations invitation qui partent
plutôt vers des joueurs faire des
joueurs d'un calibre différent
plutôt du top 20 mondial et aussi
des numéros deux ou trois norvégiens qui
peuvent être invités dans dans d'autres
tournois vous savez exactement à qui on
fait référence
pour en revenir à cette partie après le
prends des 4
on est toujours en réflexion côté
grégory grégory qui doit peut-être faire
le deuil d'une place au candidat est
acceptée accepter que il n'a pas
forcément sa place au festin du haut
niveau on est en tout cas y réfléchit
veut vraiment tout donné mais mais est
ce que cela suffit
est ce que le tout
dans nos par in
est assez pour mettre en danger un
alireza fjrca c'est la question qu'on se
pose
c'est toute la question que l'on se pose
je prends des quatre ans des quatre qui
a été jouée là au bahreïn au pari qui
sut
ali reza qui revient où il a l'air très
très tranquille alireza
ça sent la sérénité côté français il a
dû il a observé la technique de fabiano
ça c'est un peu comme
dans les mangas tu as toujours un perso
qui apprend les techniques des autres et
qui les copies est ce qu'après avoir
joué contre fabiano et ses cinq
bouteilles alireza n'a pas décidé de
copier la technique
du joueur américain et de l'employé lui
même
il va reposer sa bouteille d'eau
derrière on s'enlève là ça tombe la
veste terrible
terrible pour au bahreïn
ça va repartir
vous savez un petit peu voir la première
table
du tournoi
que dire de plus deux parties rien
un petit peu vu les possibilités
des blancs voient qu'il ya rien de très
dangereux
voit aussi le langage corporel du joueur
russe
pas forcément très positif
partant de là
complexe
mais je vois pas comment il peut mettre
en danger alireza ici honnêtement
ça me parait du domaine de l'impossible
la seule chose sur laquelle il peut
miser espéré ces cahiers reza crack
mais à mais il a l'air tellement serein
et facile
je vois pas dans quel monde
leurs pas dans quel monde ils se fait
bousculer en fait aujourd'hui
vraiment le bon appareil en dernière
ronde au paris aurait pu avoir fait quoi
que j'aurais pu y aura des joueurs plus
dur
pas vraiment parce qu'il a déjà joué au
yoyo et avoir un sévillan ça aurait
peut-être été plus embêtant mais bon
paraît pas non plus insurmontable
ça paraît pas non plus insurmontable
vous prend des six d'accord il va tenter
de la faire comme ça
donc il va y avoir c'est prend des six
il va reprendre en d4 peut-être du
cavalier
on l'a 6 shi en fait est qu'ils jouent
pas tempo c'est parce qu'il peut
éventuellement prenant b3 intermédiaire
il a pris rang des six bon ça paraît
assez logique mais sa mère était quand
même une micro réflexion
et il joue cavalier prendre des quatre
d'accord donc il va vouloir jouer contre
le pion des six
déséquilibré la position et essayer
d'obtenir du jeu avec tours a des seins
probablement y voir cavaler b6 et des 5
paraît assez logique en fait seul
problème c'est que cavalli en b6 a pas
forcément de rebond
est bien bien en
[Musique]
parquet est embourbé dans les pionts
adverse
mais qui avait b6 pour jouer des 5 1 et
essayer de casser le centre est pas
rester avec un pion des six qui pourrait
devenir une cible si les blancs
réussissent à tripler sur la colonne des
là ça pourrait être un réel problème
pour les noirs le pion pour être faible
mais bon qui avait b6 des 5e et 6e
peut-être tentés s'écarte du coup aux
caisses et doit être l'idée
mais bon là au pire à la f5
pour casser faire des cinq quand même
ouais bon il faut être il faut être un
petit peu vigilants
il faut être un peu vigilants
et d5 direct à vrai dire
en vrai ça va ed dame prend pas ce que
ça ça peut
ça a l'air d'aller aussi un
équivalent et f5 menace fourchette
web on faire un peu gaffe si des cinq
passes directes sephora
et je comprends qu'il y avait dans mon
proc et f5
donc la 5 dida ya cinq candidats ya
peut-être cinq candidats ici cavalier e
5 pour contrôler la case
beaucoup donc on va juste aller jeter un
oeil
du coup à maxime tableau 3
kébé 5 pour bekaert peut être une idée
un
calcul
aussi toujours regarder les tours france
et trois dans ses positions
las pour le mans il ya dame prend qui a
l'air qui a l'air d'aller mais aussi un
jour on for ski on prend et qu'on peut
bouffer les pions ça fait très mal
la partie shirov et/ou fin
déjà
d'être théorique
cette variante on peut la passer en
rapide
donc c'est une variante connu la bo de
binic
variante de la slave
en fait ça a dû faire un nul à une
nullité oric
en fait ils ont peut-être envie de faire
nul pour aller jouer les grands prix
fidh
comme il pouvait plus
et au départage il était trop loin les
deux
et du coup ça leur permet tous les deux
de finir à 7 points j'imagine
et donc c'est la turbo d'euros
qui est parti
pas une mauvaise nouvelle pour maxime
hodée partage
ça lui fait un demi point pour un joueur
avec les noirs c'est pas si mal
et hammam et 9,9 session qui ont fait
une ultra rapide eux aussi grave si ce
tabac sauf
il ya des nuls qui sont partis voir qui
en ont peut-être un peu marre aussi et
maxime qui envoyait le bessin qu on va
retourner sur la partie de paris de
comptes firoud déjà après le cavalier
prend des 4
spécifions remarquez vous qu'il puisse
se qualifier il faut gagner déjà et
après il ya tout un tas de conditions à
remplir
mais on verra s'ils gagnent ce qu'il en
est on va pas commencer à regarder un
peu partout la juste il ya sept nuls qui
est tombé
alors non par une trop victoire de mike
smith meilleur départager c'est la
qualif pour max un peu ça ouais
c'est un petit peu ça
dans mon cas
caruana gagne pas ouais mais 40 ce pas
lui qui gagne et puis après alors un peu
de réussite encore mais tout est
faisable 1
juin tient entièrement même si c'est des
drones ont cédé droit il fera nul max
aujourd'hui mais le truc c'est que son
adversaire veut gagner aussi donc la
partie va être un gros combat pour
maxime
séville on s'affronte important la
victoire d'antonne
la victoire dans tonnes qui peut mettre
bien
est-ce que 41 la nulle ou la gagne 1,40
à en fait le truc c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde ou nuls le qualifie
donc il peut pas jouer pour trop forcer
il veut jouer une position où il n'a pas
trop de risques
il ya un monde où nul en tout cas il
veut pas et veut pas se retrouver à
perdre fabiano parce que nul comme il a
un très bon départage c'est pas si mal
pour lui le problème serait surtout une
victoire de young y contre maxime skill
un bond et partage you
en réalité ou à un meilleur des partages
que maxime
le parti côté français
donc caruana ouais
si maxime fait nul écrire ou déjà fait
nul annuler le qualifier à quasi 100 %
du coup pas facile
vaccin on départage caruana 20 pour le
moment mais ça veut pas dire que ce sera
encore le cas demain
et partage ça a évolué pendant un
tournoi
cheyrou qui a échangé en p3 qui a
échangé en a un
qui va sûrement jouer des cinq
maintenant ça a l'air de bien s'aplanir
à ça m'étonnerait co paris ne réussisse
à mettre au supplice le joueur français
qui est une bonne nouvelle pour maxime
si je refais gagner là aussi et au
départage n'était qu'un demi pointe
derrière mvl non je pense que maxime
voulait victoire shirov pour quelle
raison parce que shirov et dans le
départage de maxime et je pense que le
plus gros adversaire au départage ce
sera pas shirov donc je pense que maxime
il aurait préféré victoire shirov
de répondre le ratio le nom de parti
blanc noir jouer dans le départage yade
et des partages qui sont comme ça ouais
ou celui qui a joué plus les noirs un
meilleur des partages d'office c'est le
départage numéro un
oui parce qu'en fait il faudrait surtout
que fabiano perdre et si fabiano père et
que maxime gagne il y est quasiment vrai
bon allez déjà on va essayer de se
concentrer sur une qualif de fuir ou
déjà et on verra après parce que là ils
s'approchent vraiment de la drau
10 elle annule ça lui fait pas peur
le clic
est pas la bonne n
calmant de feria réparer clément un prix
n'a pas le droit de perdre fabiano la
joie une immunité
genre c'est un gars qui perd jamais il
peut pas faire une gaffe qui peut pas
il faut jouer la chance à 100%
le real madrid avait bien perdu contre
le sheriff tiraspol à domicile 1
chance oui un peu de chance mais bon ça
peut arriver
ça peut donc il faut lui mettre la
pression jusqu'au bout à fabiano fabiano
il n'est pas sûr de se qualifier avec
une nulle un je vous le rappelle s'il
voulait faire nul avec les blancs
c'est clair que
que j'y croyais pas trop mais là s'il se
sent obligé de gagner pour assurer la
qualif on peut imaginer un monde où il
fait une gaffe ça existe un
sens car la victoire de quinze années
passées entre les mains non exactement
et il avait besoin de gagner pour être
sûr de se qualifier il avait perdu
magnus mais mes chroniques du cou qui
n'avait besoin que d'une nulle avait lui
aussi perdu
et magnus avait gagné les candidats du
coup sûr un concours de circonstances
incroyables
est-ce que famine et où couronne avec
les autres joueurs au fur et à mesure
rabat il peut le voir oui
commentez le match car la scène n'est
pas sûr chez sfr exactement avec fable
normalement
non il faut que maxime gagne avec les
noirs et après est à prévoir et après
espérer
c'est simple maxime il a 61 points au
départage il a 61 points d'adversaires
et caruana 61 points et demi
s'ils gagnent maxime son adversaire lui
donnera six points et demi est
l'adversaire de fabiano lui en donnera
cette donc virtuellement caruana un
point d'avancé au départage mais un
point sur sur les quatre adversaires
noms communs ou cinq adversaires nom
commun qu'ils ont joué ça se rattrape en
vrai donc maxime s'il gagne je le répète
il a une petite chance d'y aller
à l'essai le dessin est joué par par ali
reza c'est un des coups dont on parle et
qu'on imagine et puis on prendra me
prend ça à l'air très très plat
et caruana cissé ue qui gagnent il est
dans la sauce un sky où il a un
excellent départage
je crois que prêtre jouer le bon coup
d'après ce que vous avez dit
position des noirs allez on peut encore
y croire les mecs on n'a jamais été
aussi bien de la journée
on était peut-être à 1,5 pour cent en
début de journée on est peut-être à 5 6
% de chance pour maxime et pour ali reza
aussi
ça peut on peut on peut un petit peu
vibrer peut-être s'y prête que fait le
taff maxima une position complexe
maxime peut perdre aux siens mais il
peut gagner ça
parce que presque peut s'arranger avec
karwan et c'est ouais non là on a du bol
parce que caruana c'est pas le genre de
la maison
caruana le genre de la maison il va pas
envoyer un chèque de 50 milles pour
enfin je pense pas
m'étonnerais pas le genre de la maison
caruana ça
c'est pas un joueur qui inquiète là
dessus
samak réputé comme très loyal hawaï
caruana
il y en a qui le ferait il ya des
joueurs je serais plus inquiet je vais
pas dire lesquels il ya des joueurs je
serais plus inquiet
on peut y avoir des maisons plus
complexe
mais caruana c'est pas du tout le genre
de la maison
alors j'ai pas donner de noms mais il ya
des joueurs sont serais plus inquiet
c'est trop fort année ponant n'est pas
du tout genre de la maison
alors pas du tout j'ai pas du tout non
plus
bon je répondrai plus sur aucun joueur
sinon ça donnera des indices
mais en tout cas dans caruana caruana
n'est pas
clean
qui s étend du foie pas sûr qu'ils la
gagnent fab y aller moi je commence à y
croire
raya c'est terrible comme toujours je
commence à y croire
rageant peu plus pourquoi j'y crois tout
le temps les amis
j'en ai marre
je recommence à y croire bordel j'y
croyais plus j'étais tranquille je
passais un dimanche tranquille et j'y
crois racée terrils ces terribles
race terrible dire croire
je vais rejoindre un petit tweet
j'envoie 8
c'est terrible je recommence à y croire
on peut plus j'en peux plus
le départage savoir le fameux et tout
peut changer sur les résultats le razr
sar mais c'est tellement ça et là pas
position maxime est tellement
intéressante
yahya yahya il ya les amis on a vu un
peu favy fabi en sueur
alireza alireza c'est parfait et maxime
en ue en sueur
maxime qui envoie b quattro
c'est terrible ça envoie
max qui ya fait c'est tellement pas une
cave se paie quattro à yahia et les
jean-michel turbine est en sueur
lvl qui envoie le all in
you qui va devoir résister à la furia du
joueur français
il envoie il a raison maxime d'envoyer y
a que comme ça qu'il ira 1
en tout cas ça va faire douter fabiano
parce que si c'est la guerre sur cet
échiquier
fabiano il sait qu'un des deux gagnera
et il va être obligé de se découvrir le
joueur américain
il va être obligé de se découvrir mais
ce qui est extraordinaire avec le chat
c'est quand maxime force pas le gain il
a enfilé ouais il n'a pas de mental il
force pas le gain il joue tranquille
maxime force le gard avec les noirs ils
jouent à fond ouais il a fait une gaffe
il est nul
extraordinaire
précise à maxime trop prudent et quand
il envoie un an ses gaffes
c'est terrible quand on voit pas tu es
nul quand on vois tu es nul c'est
impressionnant
ça par
sa part de tous les côtés les amis c'est
peut-être la plus belle journée qu'on
est en train de vivre
à rester un petit peu sur sur ali reza
on va déjà assuré sa là parce que maxime
il a aussi besoin de la nulle d'alireza
genre tu veux qu ali reza yaye qui fasse
nul et en plus c'est une partie qui nous
intéresse de l'autre côté aussi
allez
vous cotisez pour diffuser sur un chat
je pense que si on était à 15 20 milles
5 par mois tous les mois on pourrait
peut-être l'envisager mais bon on ferait
d'autres choses je pense
dans les calmes sanchez comme c'est
absolument impossible ça c'est sûr y'a
pas il n'y a pas de solution en fait
on oh my way
et on va espérer quand même
c'est à dire les a gagnés en quoi pour
maxime ça change rien parce qu'ils ont
tous dans leur reine jeanne alireza ils
ont tous dans le temps l'heure des
partages faut pas qu'ils perdent
mais nulle ou gains et bien c'est
surtout bien pour ali reza annuler ou
bien
s'il gaffe on voit les pubs à huy les
pubs les pubs les pubs les pubs qui vont
devoir bientôt partir
ingo pro alors ça j'ai tenté la gopro
dans les tournois j'ai eut demandé à des
tournois si si j'avais quelqu'un qui
bosse pour moi qui va avec une go pro
est-ce que ça passe et ça m'a été refusé
sa part les tournois aussi
donc malheureusement la gopro marche pas
mais je mettais je vais pour un tournoi
j'avais jamais quelqu'un qui avait
possibilité d'une groupe pro pour aller
filmer juste la table de max avec notre
matos mais a trouvé une clé 4g et tout
ça aurait coûté un petit peu mais mais
je voulais le faire mais mais ça on me
la refuse et ouais
normal non non la normale
non ça c'est normal c'est normal sans
refuser en fait le seul argument pour
avoir les cams et comme on est la chaîne
des chèques organique la plus regardée
au monde pendant les tournois ça
pourrait leur donner de la visibilité ça
pourrait être un argument mais en fait
comme les échecs comment dire les
organisateurs mettent pas de l'argent
pour avoir de la visibilité y met de
l'argent pour mettre de l'argent sais
pas trop pourquoi mais bon ça c'est pas
notre problème mais du coup ils s'en
foutent de de leurs sponsors etc
ils s'en foutent complètement c'est pas
assez pas le voilà les tournois sont pas
là pour pour eux pour être gardés
ouais c'est que du mécénat c'est des
gens qui qui ont de l'argent ou c'est de
l'argent public et tout ça donc ya pas
de yap à damvix de démocratiser le jeu
courant soit
c'est pas le l'objectif principal des
tournants
k
sinon tu aurais tu t'autorise cas rien
que pour toi non nous comptons effet le
tournant les avait donné à tout le monde
criait pas grand monde qui a voulu je
crois qu'il est qu un streamer qui avait
diffusé la bi stream cap en anglais
mais non non moi je vais donner à tout
le monde un ballet qu'un
c qui coachent alireza on sait qu'ils
achètent par enough mais à mon avis nous
manque beaucoup de noms dans la liste
quand même un peu ma chambre titre est
du coup quand je trie mes actes chasse
comme on peut toujours avoir les cannes
quasiment en tout cas pour tous les
tournois en jeu de chaises cam a fait un
contrat elecam donc ça c'est un peu la
bonne nouvelle on peut sont peu
systématiquement avoir les cavs en fait
c'est pas de faire l'argent ça fait quoi
de lâcher les calmes ben je pense qu'ils
veulent pas les lâcher parce qu'ils les
ont et qu'ils veulent faire leur
retransmission avec leurs commentateurs
beau ça peut se comprendre
quand tu lâches à plusieurs millions
d'euros pour un tournoi a envie de
garder les calmes pour toi quoi non mais
je peux le comprendre en vrai
en vrai à 0,7 par rapport à ça
un vrai
investi sur les com non mais des fois tu
as des gros budgets pour les
commentaires
pas des très très gros but en anglais à
des états des bons budget pour les
commentaires
enfin beaucoup plus que ce que moi je
peux faire sur ma chaîne genre beaucoup
beaucoup plus généralement pour les
tournois il met y mettre les moyens pour
les commentaires
ouais en anglais ils ont ils ont
généralement de très bon moyen pour les
commentaires
en tout cas beaucoup plus que moi
donc non c'est pas c'est pas vrai dire
qu'il met pas les moyens pour les
commentaires
c'est conforme à clichy en grand ouais
ouais
on va rester humble ça a l'air d'aller
en pour ali reza
du coup par world chasse à quelques
années c'était scandale par contre je
suis pas d'accord avec toi mark martin
mc fly
mais bon pensent que la privatisation
des coûts c'est impossible en fait que
ça passe légalement parce que s'il n'y a
pas de monde où ça où tu pourrais les
privatiser mais on soit ça donnerait une
plus value au sponsorship donc pourquoi
pas
sakic fort ce salon va retourner chez
maxim
attendait il faut que je recadre le truc
que je regarde le truc
petit problème ici qui va être réglé
immédiatement ue qui se lève et on va
essayer de faire le bilan
il a fait cavalier f5 maxime qui a
envoyé b quattro
échange de cet échange en d4 et d'amd
quatre
ans qu'elle s'y fait dame prend des cats
est mort
et sur damas cinq dames prend des six
tours 8
ok faut jouer ça hein c'est sur faut
jouer ça et d'un prend 1,6 dame c5
mais ok ça joue
gagner une partie du jeu d'échecs
tour à tour prend ses 3
way peut-être penser 3
qui ont pensé 3 et doit y avoir damas
deux et ça fait mal
wen ont gagné une partie du jeu d'échecs
il une partie du jeu d'échecs
mettre des coups je sais pas ce que ça
donne
le truc c'est que son adversaire peut
pas faire nul non plus
ça peut-être qu'à la fin c'est dromey le
problème c'est que yuill éliminé s'il
fait droit aussi
à ouais j'aime bien votre id et ont
pensé 3 ici et tenté un temps le cloud
va tout tu tentes le bas tout ça passe
ça passe ça passe pas ça passe pas mais
au moins tu envoies
non c'est assez bien joué après à vrai
dire damas 5 d'un grand tour 8 avec mona
store français trois tours b 8 et et
dame prend 1,6 pour couvrir d'am-dam c5
ça joue aussi un
j'ai peur damas
4 ok mais il peut pas jouer ça you fuck
you il doit lui aussi gagner il va pas
serré comme ça
un an position hyper intéressante pour
maxime
ça peut passer ça peut ne pas passer
mais il ya une chance il ya un espoir
maintenant faudrait que prête que m
mettre les barbelés allez un petit mur
de barbelés peut-être pour prêtres que
je pense que maxime il n'a pas besoin de
lui arrive à faire le taf mais il faut
du barbelé pour prêtres que
alors peut-être
alors peut-être prête que met les
barbelés maxime la gagne un peu de beau
lui à gauche à droite et on y est
et on peut y être les amis
peut y être un qui sait ce qu ali reza à
mon avis ya enfin je vois pas dans quel
monde ya un risque ici
c'est la leyre vite cette position
elle a l'air complètement vie de cette
position
puis à cette pièce à moins d'une cave
d'ali reza toujours possible mais sinon
ça al'air salaires extrêmement solide
dans la partie du jour c'est vraiment
cette partie yoann vl
dans le contenu en tout cas
aussi qui réalisent ces quatre peut-être
en fait
ça ça palerme
dembele est plus intéressant que ces
deux là parce qu'il est un must win
on est calme en train de regarder la
partie de la nouvelle
sur ces 4 je pense qu'il va faire
d'apprendre et si ceux ci
nankin
à voir ce que maxime fait ça va cliquer
paris mme caf
pas qu'il ya
non non mais là il a rien aux paris mme
savoie turbo drouot part in
c'est quand même une excellente nouvelle
c'est déjà la première bonne news de la
journée si on en a déjà un ou candidats
qualifiés après après deux heures de jeu
on prend un
max à sacrifier il ya tout un tas de
variantes avec damas cinq dames des six
tours ces trois dames e7 qui sont
bordéliques
avoir l'impression cherchons faut des
normes at on va pas parler de départage
la maman dort ylo.un c'est un peu trop
tôt là pour aller voir les parties de
départage va défaut déjà avec maxime
gagne que caruana gagne pas après on
s'intéressera au départage on en est
loin à la dudh et partage
on va pas regarder des parties de
condition numéro 5 pour se qualifier on
va déjà essayer d'avoir les conditions
principales et après on ira chercher
ôter ce qu'il faut un
houssin il envie d échec pas des
tournois mais oui il peut en vivre mais
pas que des tournois
des tournois
à deux façons il damas cinq pour jouer
aux quilles a peut-être du tout repenser
4 qui s écarte aussi mesdames prenez
garde c'est sûr que vous
propose d'amener cette dame b cette
remarque aussi pasillo
dame prendre ici c'est
à météo france et 3 dans le 3e set
k
j'ai appris vraiment complexe en fait il
a beaucoup d'options maxime
ça manque depuis voit exactement voilà
ça c'est une bonne réflexion dans le
tchat j'avais oublié la pub il y avait
un moment chaud donc on n'a pas misé
dans mon cas
interview dans le top 10 on vit
confortablement après les autres faut se
diversifier
ouais jusqu'au top top 50 tu vis quand
même top 10 suivi très confortablement
c'est plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'euros par an et puis plus tu descends
puce est bas mais mais top santé déjà
pas très bien quoi jusqu'à tab 5 ans tu
dois vivre correctement
mais après duras
après difficile
je vous dise oui car à plat plus bas
après je sais pas pourquoi vous
maudissez celui qui a rappelé la pub ce
qui est quand j'en avais pas assez c'est
moi qui me fais défoncer après donc
c'est pas pas très cool en fait merci à
celui qui a qui a parlé de la pub 1
toutes les armes au yen à lancer six
minutes par heure
donc merci à lui 1
après la pub s'appelle daniel renshaw
s'est tellement ça
maintenant en grand les amis
maxime qui peut faire le taf il joue
contre un adversaire masqué aujourd'hui
masqué de vs masque aide
mais par caruana on reviendra sur
caruana après le coup de maxime
à ces masques et il est obligé de mettre
le masque c'est uniquement leur
politesse c'est de la politesse
mais à mais les joueurs font ce qu'ils
veulent
il en est où fille rousse et ça se passe
très bien pour le moment
maxime qui a trouvé le damas 5 et oui
les amis
on commence à y croire on commence à
espérer
c'était sûr que ça à l'envoyer
alors peut-être alors peut-être les amis
le requin est de sortie
liu qui sut
ils s'enrichissent or il joue les coups
la maxime
east aux étoiles peut-être keith aux
étoiles d' aller on peut un peu y croire
voir les amis on peut y croire allez on
est à 1,5 pour cent là on a huit ou neuf
pour cent de chances de qualif on est en
train en train de stokes et c'est comme
les beach boys les amis
ceux qui ont vendu à 800 à 800 dollars
sont en sueur et oui les amis ceux qui
pensent que les 8% ne vont pas continuer
à monter peuvent tuer
parce que ça va passer de 8% à 15 puis à
28 à 50 puis à 100 les amis
ça va le faire que monter tout au long
de la journée les actions de maxime sont
à prendre maintenant
après ce sera trop tard
ça marche même au tour de maxime maxime
par contrat qui abandonne le concours de
marche quand même
terrible il pourrait se faire rattraper
à la marche heureusement qu'il a fait
l'écart dans les rondes précédentes
voyez les concentrés de ou fly ou en
sueur
éval de new mais arrêtez de parler
d'ordinateurs les amis regardez les
positions regarder les coûts les coûts
qui partait matching qui par marché
ouais quand même il prend pas trop de
retard
ça envoie maxime qui tente le tout pour
le tout qui fait plaisir au public
aujourd'hui
et d'un prend des six tours france et 3
et ça va envoyer du très très lourd
et en tout et en plus ça doit mettre de
la pression à fabien de tout ça parce
que cette partie on a du mal à imaginer
qu'elle se solde par la nulle
et fabiano et fabiano qui peut qui peut
la force et qui peu de show qui peut
douter
c'est bien joué aussi de la part de
yuuwaa qui a accepté le combat même s'il
a un petit peu inférieur à maxime il
accepte le combat donc il est parti avec
un petit avantage dans la position en
contrepartie maxime est un meilleur
joueur
et ça envoie un 50 50 mais liu qui n'a
pas fermé le jeu qui veut lui aussi
gagner pour aller aux candidats essaient
caruana qui pourraient se retrouver le
dindon de la farce phare cède et il est
changé d'âme fabiano bon il peut y avoir
peut-être dan franck et 17 pays ces cinq
familles qui étaient en difficulté
aujourd'hui contre prête que le joueur
russe
l'amitié russo pakistanaises qui
pourrait
qu'ils pourraient carrier aujourd'hui
avec un petit haut par ina qui fait
aussi une drôle et rouscoff qui peuvent
qui peuvent aider or là est-ce que ça à
partir en dame des huit cas ici 4 dan
des cinq gros
clin d'oeil d'
ça peut ça peut très bien se passer là
ça peut très bien se passer alireza
peut-être à deux doigts de du demi point
maxime non-combat caruana qui sut
on y croit les amis on n'y a jamais
autant cru depuis ce matin
ce que le président aurait tiré quelques
ficelles en coulisses c'est possible
c'est tout à fait possible
je le sens craquer le chinois
je sens le joueur chinois craquer
je le sens pas tenir la pression maxime
ici
position est trop tactique trop trop
complexe maxime il en a gagné beaucoup
des partis comme celle-là en 2018 et les
joueurs après ont complètement arrêté de
jouer ce genre de position contre lui
parce qu'il est il est intouchable
là ça peut
ça peut vraiment est difficile pour eux
on va voir après il y avait des
variantes ou y avait des perpète à la
fin mais le truc c'est que normalement
ue ne peut pas faire nul s'il fait nul
hyper entre guillemets
donc si on prend en compte qui peut pas
rentrer dans ses variantes là ça va être
très dangereux
ça peut le faire
je pense en lice position de passer mais
en langue il va trouver que la prise de
la tour n'est pas bonne on va arrêter de
vous inventer des life avec le fait que
les gens voient beaucoup de choses en
longues aux siens dans les positions
très compliqué en longues ils voient pas
tous hein
you will et 2710
il va finir comme comme dans la série
éponyme
youpi retentissement et poils au nom il
dit pas ça
est ce que je ne veux pas juste vouloir
assurer une place pour les grands prix
mais arrêtez de vous inventer des life
regardez la tête de la partie il aurait
voulu il aurait voulu s'assurer une
place avec une nulle tu penses qu'il
fasse froid ici où tu penses qu'il fait
le fou 3 et qui répète le truc de sachy
quirion frérot réfléchissez et regarder
les parties y joue la gagne il ouvre le
jeu le joueur chinois s'est pas petit
bras côté you you il a accepté le combat
il est pas là pour faire un nul non plus
ses coûts 10 qui joue le gain font
regarder les parties des amis pour
pouvoir juger
très très clairement très clairement on
voit que ue veut jouer la gagne il va
pas il va pas changer son fusil d épaule
son masque de côté tout à son honneur
d'ailleurs bien sure you il a une place
au candidat il va la tenter il passe il
passe il passe pas il passe pas et puis
voilà
mais ils jouent ils jouent le jeu hein
ils jouent le jeu le joueur chinois
ding et rennes et à l'eau candidat ou un
gâteau est à l'eau candidat il se dit
pourquoi pas moi faillissent l'audience
chinois après ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
pensent en par lui-même comme on dit
pourquoi pas moi en chinois pour voir un
peu ce qui peut penser
pourquoi
pas
je vais regarder un
traduction
en chinois
en mandarin
voie
royale aux chinois
ouais ouais y voyez mes bougies mots il
se dit why chez mes beaux chevaux din
biren wang hao wang chen et bouchots
c'est ce qui est peut-être en train de
se dire
pourquoi pas moi
c'est peut-être ce qu'il est en train de
se dire you
alors avec un meilleur accès que moi
bien sûr mais mais c'est peut-être ce
qu'ils pensent il est cantonné est bon
on va regarder en cantonais
si c'est pas en mandarin son contenu
désolé pour la prononciation mais bon
c'était pour essayer d'apprendre quelque
chose un
an chinois simplifié
annoncée du mandarin
vous raconter n'importe quoi
en station et dégueulasse à temps
voilà ce qui se dit
pourquoi pas moi
c'est ce qui peut se dire avec la bonne
conscience y on
sait ce qui peut se dire pourquoi pas
moi ils y sont allés j'ai envie d'y
aller aussi loin chez le chien très dur
la prononciation g1 j'ai un ami qui a
appris le mandarin
donc à moitié russe un nom qui va de
bacilles peut pas le parler m'a dit la
prononciation c'est le plus dur
ouais
donc
donc c'est est ce qu'il est en train de
se dire dans sa tête
oh
écoutez la position et complexes 1
je suis pas raciste c'est quoi le
rapport en fait
n'importe quoi dans le chat des fois
vous êtes vraiment insupportable
pression' ans c'est impressionnant
je vais être obligé de remettre en émaux
tony puisque ça repart dans le n'importe
quoi ça repart en émaux tony parce qu'il
ya trop de trop dit durant fait
désolé désolé les gars mais
mais mais le niveau d'idiotie est trop
trop important en fait
à partir d'un certain niveau ça repart
en est votre ligne a pas de n'y a pas de
monde en fait
et motta doit non mais ça fait du bien à
tout le monde sa part aidé un peu
réfléchir
donc
parti
ça réfléchit en tout cas côté ue
c'est tellement complexe comprend des
six tours france et 3
sassus ça sue à grosses gouttes 1
bah c'est sûr sue à grosses gouttes côté
ue
la position est vraiment complexe il ya
dame prend des six tours france et 3 qui
parle
et il sait que maxime calcul mieux que
lui
c'est vraiment difficile
psychologiquement là
et que tu as alireza turp annuler signé
position a changé on va les juges jeter
un oeil furtif
et ça ait changé et qu'ils avaient des
f-5 qu il veut faire une fourchette
cible
les résas ça à faire nul c'est sûr
allez c'est la première bonne nouvelle
c'est la preuve bonne nouvelle de la
journée
une première nul qui se profile
ça réfléchit tiens l'iresa
jérémy la partie de maxime on va aller
c'est quand même maxime c'est la partie
en plus ça va être une belle partie
alireza on reviendra évidemment
quand ça évoluera mais a vraiment plus
de vie dans la position
alors qu'il y en a dans la position de
maxime
alors qu'il ya beaucoup de vies dans la
position de maxime
il ya une vie
incroyable avec des coûts qui peuvent
partir
elle a maintenant c'est à nous de
prendre la décision et ce qui rentre
dans l'âme prend des six tours en c3
avec
plusieurs variantes extrêmement complexe
est-ce qui joue un autre coup gerbe son
qu'il a un peu forcé en fait
c'est ça le problème pour pour you
c'est qu'il a un petit peu forcé de
rentrer dans ce combat et c'est pas le
combat qu'ils souhaitaient avoir
c'est pas
souhaitait avoir côté chinois
après c'est comme ça qui peut la gagner
aussi mais face à un monstre comme
maxime espérer une erreur de calcul
serait bien présomptueux de la part du
joueur
c'est à dire qu'il ya du pays du soleil
levant et pays soleil devancé le
japonais
soleil levant sa être le japon bat façon
il ya le drapeau avec le soleil levant
donc
drapeau de quoi
faire quoi comme analogie
le pays de la grande muraille un peu
moche
c'est un peu moche mais en tout cas vous
m'avez compris
complexe complexe complexe
ça joue aussi dans la tête mais bon là
ça je veux surtout dans le calcul il n'a
pas le choix il est obligé de rentrer
dans le combat ue et il peut
complètement déraillé 1
où il ya eu la glissade non
hausse à trembloter con ça a joué côté
ue où il a tremblé quand il a joué la
leçon qu'il a fait d'un prend des 6000
ha tremblay roy ya une glissade il ya
une glissade chef
il n'a pas été serein quand il a pris le
pion 1
il est il est par william saurin
alors il est pas serein
très fébrile fébrile
ça glisse héros et regarder maxime
rouleau la maxime il est prêt à envoyer
un
maxi 1000 epr est envoyée
chambas ce qu'il en chemise col mao ue
j'adore les chemise col mao
possible je n'ai pas pu bien voir
il faut qu'ils aillent tu chanterais le
plan du jura le plan de jeu c'est
d'envoyer un c l'envoya d'agencés rien
ce que ça donne je sais pas ce que ça
donne
on peut envoyer de partout hein on peut
entendre une position comme ça qui est
complètement folle
position mais il peut aussi jouer tours
pour menacer tout repenser trois
hypers à la position hyper complexe et
deux coups sont possibles
surtout prendre 3 d'apprendre ces matins
on selon leur dis
moi j'avais foi de tout repenser 2 mai à
peut-être plus fort il ya peut-être
damas de roi c'est un
gamin roi des deux
dames prend b2 dam des huit cavaliers f8
ok il ya peut-être un match comme ça
ton français 3
voilà procès de louis non c'est un
procédé moi j'ai vu fouet 5 pardon fois
que je me suis trompé de variantes droit
c'est un tour pensait d'eux pourra
penser de tous points 5 désolé je me
suis planté
je me suis planté sur ce que j'avais vu
tout à l'heure
ok
et qu'est ce que ça donne ça j'en sais
rien mais ça n'a probablement pas
pouvoir donner mieux que nul donc maxime
j'imagine qui va jouer tours 8
dans sa position tout à l'heure mais où
il a plus rien caruana
taranaki a plus rien dans le moteur
mecar rhône en fait faut absolument qui
est venu dans la partie de maxime ou que
maxime gagne
touré 8
l'autre variante semblé donner trop de
draw dans leur âge maxime qui gardent
des pièces et qui menace tout reprend
ses 3
je la sens bien les amis je la sens bien
quand j'ai envie de dire alors peut-être
famille qui a dépensé beaucoup d'énergie
dans les trois parties précédentes et
qui en a plus dans le moteur
puis d'essence dans le tank
à sézanne pas si facile prénom mais je
suis très très un an
ça me prend ainsi soin nous fait voir
j'ai du mal à voir la finalité van dam
des quatre ans
tu veux dame b5 damas fuite et puis
tombé huit tours c8 et on envoie tout un
c'est risqué mais ça envoie
il donne tout après on verra si ça passe
ou si ça ne passe pas
mais au moins on tente
et prête que et mieux
fait que et mieux et alireza et alireza
ça va complètement et résa
il va falloir mettre la grande muraille
1 pour ayew
pour exister aux français
des cinq fait mal peut-être mais
la position et y en a de partout là les
amis
[Musique]
ben le matériel et puis un peu
l'activité après je connais pas
l'évaluation et qui a aidé 5 seul coup
moi j'étais sûr d'impro insiste par
exemple
c'est du jeu à trois résultats quand je
dis que ça va
je sais pas si les blancs sont mieux les
noirs sont mieux j'en sais rien je
sais pas quand je dis que ça va c'est
dire que je vois des chances réciproque
pour les deux pressés à ce qui est un
joueur qui est beaucoup qui ce qui soit
beaucoup mieux mais là je pense qu à
l'instant à cet instant là de la partie
les joueurs eux-mêmes ne savent pas
mais l'impression d'aller rezaï a rien
sur l'échiquier donc c'est facile
ça sent
prêt je peux très bien me tromper un
mais bon vu les vitesses de de réflexion
et tout ça ça va
c'est passé à faire d'emprunt 6 ou pas
j'en sais rien je ne sais pas
quand on prend ces trois avaient trop de
droits
tellement chaud aujourd'hui
[Musique]
vingt six salles coffre f6 raciste va
tellement perdre après tour c6 ton franc
sa pâle sur cette dernière journée ouais
tout peut se passer encore
tout peut arriver
3 oui c'est pas mieux non mais bon on va
pas discuter ce qu'il faut jouer sur
fonds propres ainsi ses amis de façon il
va pas le faire
net avantage
après 5 auquel tu penses mais le truc
c'est qu'il faut tomber sur le bon coup
créée très complexe
alors on à valros car on a fait nul
il est en grand danger en fait
on peut se retrouver en grand danger
on commence vraiment y croire on était
peut-être à 8 9% là on est à 12 % malin
de se qualifier parce que prête que
commence à avoir une bonne position
là on est à 12 % maintenant 12 % de
chances de qualif
ça augmente petit à petit
pas de mental fabiano
c'est de mettre au niveau du chat sur
les commentaires de partis pas de mental
est là ça sent la répète ça sent alireza
aux candidats
l on va mettre la caméra en grand ça
peut répéter
kiev 7 qui est des quatre dames 7 y
avait des f-5 dame si ça l'est bon allez
alireza vas-y répète frérot
ça répète il va y aller les amis
il va y aller on va le suivre en direct
on va le voir
alireza qualifiés aux candidats les amis
ça répète c'est la drau et voilà en aide
aux français qui va les amis un de nos
français aux candidats un premier
qualifié
c'est chose faite les ennemis à
l'instant 15h20 heure française 2h20 de
jeu et alireza se qualifie va fort que
l'arbitré valide mais bon dans tous les
cas vu que les deux joueurs woerth veut
le faire drôle y aura pas de problème
c'est validé je l'avais validé d'un
drôle adroit et validés et alireza qui
se qualifient aux candidats après
caruana et duda la coupe du monde
radjabov la wild card quatrième qualifié
ali reza firoud déjà sera de la partie
l'année prochaine pour affronter le
futur champion du monde pour tenter en
tout cas de gagner une place pour
l'affronter c'est le premier qualifié
via un tweet qui va partir il ya un
tweet qui part
par jour - tweet
génie
après j'en vois ça
le tweet qui est parti immédiatement
belle qualif en tout cas ça fait plaisir
donc ça c'est la première goutte 12 de
la journée on va maintenant aller voir
you you qui a envoyé le cavalier dessine
co
la partie et chaudun
la partie qui est bouillante
allez maintenant maxime on en a deux et
pour après bac et au grand prix fier d
on est bien
c'est que le brasseur on va suivre
pouvoir suivre un fr aux candidats ce
ton que ça
donc ce de folie et les a mis
à l'essai fait c'est le premier après
y'a pas eu la paix était sous pression
ça a bien joué de a à z
ça a bien joué de a à z n'a jamais été
sous pression dans la partie d'alireza
on n'a même pas eu le temps de trembler
qu'il a dominé de le sujet de la tête et
des épaules
la le coût pour maxime c'est peut-être
tama 4 1 pour taper ces deux tapes et e4
taper des cinq étapes et f4 taper h 1
tapez partout
ça a parfois qu'un fr va chercher la
qualif respecte etienne bacrot s'il te
plaît bacardi tôt
aux méritants banda fin
on respecte quand meme le président
s'est déjà qualifié aux candidats
faut-il le rappeler
et on fait alors une belle s'est jamais
qualifiée aux candidats techniquement
techniquement et sur maxime ils auraient
raison
mais
il les a joués mais s'est jamais
qualifié mais ba qui s'est qualifié
respecte le président quand même moins
respecte le président
qui s'était pas le même format
du coup comme c'est pas le même format
on va dire qu'il s'est jamais qualifié
ol n 6 soyons sérieux et joël aux tirs
et si oui je crois qu'il avait joué un
candidat
chaque sac ida son format donc
tu veux jouer le sens qu'a effectuée
lors ouais mais tu es qualifia les lots
du coup aussi un mode de qualification
quelque part
ce qui a bien joué alireza
belle qualif
n'a pas le même format mais on a le même
bagouet sujet xavier bien joué
c'est pas ce qui a été qualifié d'office
ouais mais ce qui l'était déjà français
quand ils étaient qualifiés aux
candidats a peut-être
un
un liqin ça compte aussi aller keane il
est devenu champion du monde à les kin
aller qui ne s'était pas qualifié
candidats à ces champions du monde il
était déjà français au moment où il est
devenu champion du monde en tout cas il
a gagné un titre de champion du monde en
étant français ça c'est sûr
c'est un vrai aussi de prendre
du lots ne pas l'oublier
aulas le vélo tu t'en fous où il s'est
qualifié les qualifiés 1
mais pas d'eau ni peuple français penche
volontiers passé devenu pendant ou juste
avant je crois juste avant
est ce qu'un verre passe qualifié avec
un autre tournoi oui oui il m'a et
maxime va se qualifier maintenant mais
ils pourraient avoir un repêchage au cas
où
donc
maintenant parti de maxime
cette partie de max
sûrement partiront damas quatre ont des
cinq aussi possible peut-être pour
éviter qu'un rallye au 7 mai doit
calculer ça
ça doit être le cas dans ma 4e set pour
prendre à me prendre dame ces deux juan
damas k3 bien damas de maths
dames 1 4 en fait
sa menace issifou détroit qui pourrait
être une option ça doit être cavaliers
prend les dames c'est 2 donc ça il peut
pas donc damas quatre en fait ça doit
être tout rage 2
ça couvre le pion
et du coude 1.4
complexe c'est complexe
c'est complexe
ok c'est hyper compliqué
de
rang des 500
ans le quat'sous prendre quatre et il
n'y a pas assez il n'y a pas assez
ok damas quatre tours age 2
complexe
g pas où tu peux en mettre ici
mettre tellement de partout
complexe complexe
il faut prendre 5 e
est ce la souffrance en fait cette
connerie
cavale c'est quatre fronts dame prend
sur camaïeu 7 prendre en damas de roy c1
dames un roi des deux dames prend b2 ah
ok très chaud on va pas aller plus loin
parce que durée van
damme à 4 tours age 2
du coup qui avale ses quatre prix ces
quatre dames c4
la turbine est dit qu à tour hd2
c'est quoi le matos seuil honte de plus
pour les blancs
elle n'a peut-être pas assez pour max en
fait
c'est un peu
d'analysé en vraie dame à quatre ça a
pas l'air cool comme coup
faim car c'est peut-être un coup de
chiottes
courage de efforts
sécuritaires ce candidat est ensuite
carlson il sera le plus jeune a chez le
champion du monde a vu que le plus jeune
actuel ça doit être karl scène
ouais s'ils gagnent les candidats et qui
bat carlson sera le plus jeune ouais
c'est pas le plus jeune à l'eau candidat
fischer a dû aller à 16 17 ans j'avais
fait une série là dessus sur ses parties
aux candidats et comment il s'est
qualifié mais comme ça remonte
évidemment je me rappelle pas de l'âge
exact
mais vous pouvez aller voir sur la
chaîne ya plusieurs partis analyse et
donc sera pas le plus jeune à l'eau
candidat mais
mais s'il ya un champion du monde sera
le plus jeune à le devenir et du coup
quel coup on peut regarder
en d5 aussi possible d'en prendre et
cinq
dames c'est cette
courageuse de dire
en deux ans raf est peut-être rien
peut-être car ils plus
ça doit jouer à quelques mois ou
quelques semaines
mais gary ça un peu spécial
ce que le premier match il a été remis
et toubon façon il est tellement de
choses spéciales en histoire des échecs
20 premiers matches interminables du
coup qui a été remis qui a été gagné par
personne
tellement en bordel
mais bon c'est sûr que ali rezaï sera
plus jeune que s'il ya une aide mais il
gagnera pas normalement
ça a l'air d'être un peu short ça pour
gagner
ça a l'air d'être short ça pour gagner
des traits nigel pour gagner
à
trouver une autre solution
pour ces six est-ce que c'est pas un
coup un peu malin ça parce que carey
lieu ça tient pas
une femme b 4
suite il croit way caïds et cinq rôles
ou quand même j'avais pas imaginer à
quel point ces terres aux loups comme
coup
le coup fait un peu mal le coup fait un
peu mal honnêtement la série de coups
l'a fait mal côté côté chinois mais bon
le jeu est ouvert 1 mais juste j'ai peur
que ça perdent le piquant
j'ai peur que ce soit pas due soit plus
du piment habanero mais ce soit du
piment d'espelette maintenant dans cette
partie est terrible
c'est terrible
c'est absolument terrible
c'est 5 et sur ses 5 ya pas y avoir une
merde avec vous prend 1,5
ça pue fou prend 1,5 ça
il ya comme
abbas a fait perdre trop de coordination
apprennent sur damas quatre qui
paraissait coup c'est ce courage de en
fait j'ai complètement sous-estimé
genre t'es tu fous prendra me prend qui
a valu à vie six partir là dedans
mais bon en fait ça j'ai peur qu'on
gagne jamais
on va récupérer ou quatre mais ça tu vas
jamais gagné avec les noirs
en fait je vois pas de trucs pimenter ce
que je cherche pour les noirs c'est pas
une bonne et varel en fait je m'emballe
avec ses dépositions où
il ya quelque chose en fait et damas
quatre tours h2 j'arrive pas à trouver
comment comment taper
je n'arrive pas à voir comment on va
taper
saku fait tout est trop couvert
fallait peut-être ça qui en c3 mais cinq
ans et 3 il y avait trop de trop dans
leur âge mais il fallait peut-être joué
la psychologie genre si tu draw the draw
et on est tous les deux éliminés du coup
tu peux pas rentrer dans les trucs de
drones non plus
il a joué dans max et envoyé damas
quatre
bombes à
mûr de thé nul hier savez quand même
marché maxime a raté le tour prend 1,5
mais c'est un peu marché
mûr de thé nul en fait seule chance hein
allez on tente on tente
si ça passe ça passe à
le tournage de fait trop mal par contre
si la pâte ou rage 2 c'est fini tout de
l'autre côté allez y a plus que ça
allait on peut y aller
allez on peut aller sur le mur
un mur peut peut passer
un mur peut pas et
c'est terrible
ces stores h2 j'arrive pas j'ai pas la
réf bon vas-y on va essayer de penser au
cou au retour h2 donc fou des trois
sapeurs en fait ce qui est con c'est
qu'il faut qu'on trouve [ __ ] il a fait
il est bon il est bon ue
par le mur de thé nul va infuser
joué
assez bien joué c'est bien joué en fait
y avait pas d'autres coûts
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un cavalier 3
alors qu'ils détestent je voulais tout
rêve de créer des quatre mais tu
reprends des quatre rien
c'est terrible
je fais que des miss clic
avant un coup
vous prendra me prends pour b8
hockey
puisque sa joie est un peu ou pas cette
histoire mais maintenant on n'a plus les
fous pour taper les chevaux n'ont pas de
casque d'accès parce qu'ils sont bloqués
par les fous fait les chevaux cd casser
des pièces d'attac ou reportés donc en
gros pour pouvoir attaquer le roi
faudrait qu'ils soient en fait sur une
de ces casa
et ça on va pas le mettre ça on va pas
le mettre ça pour jump ici pour jeunes
pour jam fait frais qu'ils soient dans
ce secteur là mais on a accès à r en
fait on n'a pas accès à ça on n'arrive
pas à avoir accès à ça parce qu'on n'a
pas accès à bessens qui le cavaly
éloigné ça s'est attaché à sa est en
fait on arrive par année les chevaux
quoi
le c6 pour calvé 4
6 et 6
tu l'ès 17 en l'air avec le québécois
trop
peut-être
il ya un monde
et il a fait vous prend des 5es ce qui
peut se tromper
voilà c'est d'apprendre de toute façon
c'est sûr
maxime du coup on a on lui a reproché un
petit peu de ne pas avoir tenté sa
chance il donne tout là
on est redescendu à 4% là on est
redescendu a pas beaucoup et
sûre et plus de 40 ha soit gagnant et on
serait pas bien
et c'est 4 de citoyennes et à pâques et
ses 4 parce que prise prise il ya 17 ans
l'air
il a par trop dans cette maxime ouais il
a décidé de pas faire le tour prend ces
trois qui est intéressant de faire tout
re 8 que j'aimais bien aussi et du coup
quel vallée des saints qui était
vraiment très fort il a dû comme moi
sous-estimé
sinon il aurait fait tout reprend ses
droits
donc et connaissant maximy se lève quand
même
je pense que ça veut dire je leur mette
en grande calmes
après you est un must win aussi alors
peut-être
peut-être dame prend cavalli f6 justin
quand même tu veux juste sa dame b 3
pardon et je sais pas tu bouffes 4
ok la position reste chaude et you must
win
tu quoi temps me swing tu vas être tu
vas pas pouvoir serrer la vis pour la
gagner tu as les chevaux tu as des
pièges à peut-être tanzanie mais bon il
ya maison youth et solide 1 c'est pas le
cas que t'as plus envie de jouer
mais tour ces trois c'était peut-être un
coup de bluff fouet avec yuki pouvait
craquer mentalement
mais youla avec l' avantage c'est sûr
qu'il va la forcer un il n'y a pas de
monde ou you serre la vis ici
je veux dire la joue avec la vie serré
en mode de résultats georges prend
vraiment zéro risque nul me convient il
va être obligé de
2,2 de la gagne et donc il peut
théoriquement se découvrir
il peut faire conneries à tout moment où
ses positions c'est pas comme comme
fabiano phare -et non mais fabien de la
pression était un peu plus simple à
jouer quand même mais la vraie c'est
fabiano quand il a vraiment joué max
toulon la danse est partie la une une
erreur peut arriver à tout moment
j'ai l'impression qu'ils jouent perfecto
si aujourd'hui ça joue bien
et cavaliers fcc c'était sûr en fait par
déduction carré d as she c'était la
seule
ue 36e mondial mais il est maigre
mais les maigres il est malgré l'été
dans les 27 78 pensent 27 60
qui est numéro 2 ou 3 de l'équipe de
chine c'est un joueur très très solide
un but l'anguille
t'aurais plus l'impression de le voir à
27,40 aujourd'hui 27 30 27 40 15 27 04 1
franchement c'est 27 04 je comprends
même pas comment il a un aussi petit et
l'eau en fait je sais pas pourquoi on
fait à vrai dire on en parlait avec fab
en début de tournoi on comprenait pas
in donc largement est loin de soi et
s'ils jouent que en dernièrement six
jours en chine je patrouille c'est parti
je voulais ligue chinoise il ya
peut-être d'autres tournois fermés ou
quoi et la basse avec tout le monde est
très souple ac c'est terrible
supportable
ils sont
il joue un peu en vase clos et ils sont
des gars forts
en plus d'anciens adversaires de maxime
qui sont très bien ça peut le faire
remonter au départage je pense là que
s'ils gagnent en vrai vu la position de
fabi but où il est quasi à 50% de
chances de qualif à vrai dire
parce que fabi va pas la gagne et si
vous dites ces anciens de la résidence
de ses adversaires de maxime joue bien
il ya qu'un point d'écart au départage
c'est rien ça peut clutch
you heureux que record à 27 65 kg et
divers 27 67 70 quelque chose comme ça
c'était sur ces maisons très solide
je crois qu'on les cas les noirs gagne
par erreur pourquoi pas
si on a fait nul et maxime gagne pour le
moment les départager t'as plus pour
cornet - 2
op art in einem au paris-nice et dead
ramage se foutait
terrible
mise au point
de
aller en let's go
d'autres prêtres mal en fait s'il prête
que gagne si maxime est prête que gagne
ses coups l'un
des deux français 4 s'avère d'année mais
presque qui sort sa gamme en
s'y prête que la gagne et que maxime la
gagne paille face ce sera une mère de
regrets
la jordan ayew pourrait qu'on est ici
llamas d'erreur à commettre ici déjà est
ce qu ils considèrent que dame b3 il va
gagner tu ailles peut dire d'un mp3 d'un
prend b3 qui les prend 1,4 fou prend
assise bon feeling connerie j'ai passé
ses sept finales exactement mais il peut
dire que ça il va pas réussir à gagner
et qu'il faut mieux garder les dames en
fait faut espérer que liu
ils jugent mal un truc parce que drouot
et pas dans son règne parce que you il
un meilleur comme gisèle un meilleur des
partages que maxime et si lui y gagne et
que fabien ne gagne pas il ya de grandes
chances qu'ils aillent aux candidats
donc qu il a tellement tout à gagner et
il a aussi du coup tout à perdre vu la
partie de fabiano donc pour nous en fait
le scénario pour mettre la pression ayew
est les parfaits mais il faut qu'ils
déconnent
il n'a pas le droit dans son règne quoi
ça peut ça ça peut être notre chance
quoi
pas loin des regards des autres jusqu'à
bien sûr ils le font d'ailleurs
après une gaffe ça arrive toujours de
manière inattendue à regarder la partie
de nayer contre firoud déjà ça
paraissait le coup qu'a joué d'ailleurs
c'est impossible en fait je jure que
même en blitz le coup mort est choqué je
le redis à va réviser tes finale frérot
il a réfléchi 25 minutes pour faire un
cookie hallucinant
il arrive de temps en temps le coup de
bol en fait en la réussite comme dans
tous les sports
au tennis le ce match raté quoi le ce
match bas du filet ce match va du petit
qui attend pas quoi tu as des voix djoko
ce match facile et bim badufle tu sais
pas pourquoi on fait mais ça fait le
break et ça change un match
la réussite fait partie intégrante de
tous les sports 1
aussi des arbitres qui voit parfois des
en avants qui n'existe pas au sol quand
tu relâche le ballon ça peut arriver
tu mets des essais de génie est à larbi
tu sais pas pourquoi il que le refuge
sur un en avant qui n'existe pas
soixante mètres avant on sait même pas
pourquoi il revient sur l'action en fait
ça arrive ben du coup laissé pas
accepter tu sais même pas pourquoi après
le match en fait
je sais pas écoutez une décision comme
ça qui part on sait pas pourquoi
pourquoi
un exemple au hasard
réception sans la loi s arrive aussi tu
as une chandelle tonga y vient avec la
main le ballon touche sa main il va sur
la tête en avant de l'adversaire et il
n'y a pas en avant quoi
tu sais pas trop pourquoi tu dis les
règles ont changé
ça arrive c'est autre chose qui arrive
du coup tu te prend un essai c'est pas
trop pourquoi mais
c'est le sport
donc on va voir mais tout peut tout peut
arriver tu peut t'arriver
tout arrivé non mais des gaffes on en a
déjà vu des erreurs on en a vus aux
échecs ça arrive pas souvent mais ça
arrive bel exemple de d'ailleurs c'était
le meilleur 1 c'est le meilleur exemple
c'est genre de truc qui arrive jamais
et c'est le genre de chose qui n'arrive
jamais
et pourtant et pourtant ça arrive c'est
pour ça qu'on regarde ainsi les joueurs
étaient des machines on arrêterait de
regarder un
mais bon là après dame b3 qui semble dam
des trois qui semble être le coup mais
ça joue encore une façon ils jouent pas
tempo il n'est pas sûr de lui il peut
commencer à gamberger on sait pas on
sait pas s'ils se passe dans la tête des
gens
il reste trente minutes 15 coups à jouer
qui se passe tellement de choses dans
une partie d'échecs
après généralement le problème à ce
niveau là c'est qu'ils font très peu de
fautes c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
d'ailleurs à ce niveau-là genre ce
serait une partie de mon lait veulent
c'est 50 50 1 je vous annonce qu'à mon
level cette game c'est 50 50
on ne sait pas en fait tout peut arriver
mais alors genre vraiment n'importe quoi
à mon lait veulent c'est n'importe quoi
faut que je remette une pub là j'allais
oublier
pour les vols à sega langues
mais moi
votre faute mais ils font des fautes
justement quand ils sont sous une grosse
pression psychologique il y aussi les
retombées à 2700 il ya aussi des raisons
même s'il est maigrichon mêlée des 27 60
il est plus qu'à 27 donc c'est plus le
grand ue de la grande époque peut-être
qu'il choque un peu dans ses positions
tout peut arriver un faut pas être
défaitiste et amis
via une position sage ou en fait
c'est une position où il ya moyen de se
tromper
c'est super bien et s'il avait une vidéo
maxime qui a causé 500 pour une partie
assez difficile en fait pendant une
partie
complexe
ces
positions tu peux te bourrer il ya
beaucoup de candidats il ya beaucoup
d'erreurs possibles
mais clairement le fait que fabiano soit
pas gagnant ça nous arrange tellement
parce qu'on le voit là que fabiano il va
pas la gagner celle-là ça tu vas jamais
gagné avec les blancs normalement à
moins de gap machin nanani nanana mais
c'est pas une position avec un gros
potentiel de gaffe tu vas prendre v5
c'est plutôt fabi qui pourrait même la
perdre à mon avis perdre j'exagère
peut-être mais ça ça ça file vers draw
et du coup ils pourraient même craqué en
voulant faire se forcer le gain parce
que ça va deux rochers chéu mvl
parce que je gère ça peut que ça va pas
de rouge justement chez yum veille ou
peut la gagner si hugh gagne sa force
quasiment fabi a gagné donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qui peuvent se passer
encore aujourd'hui
le scénario est certes pas complètement
positif parce que maxime est pas gagnant
mais c'est mieux qu'une position ferme
et il envoie dame b 3 il envoie le dmp 3
pas de bluff mais il va falloir qu ils
en envoient beaucoup des coûts
d'emprunt 4 tempo c'est bien ce que fait
max allez mon max c'est ça qu'il faut
faire faut lui mettre la pression jouer
tempo c'est bien ce qui fait là c'est
bien ce qui fait et continue continue y
a que comme ça qu'on va le faire craquer
il faut y aller faut y aller faut lui
faire mal
maxime c'est un orfèvre pour ça il faut
jouer vite il faut faire craquer
évidemment il n'est pas bien évidemment
eu l avantage mais il ya qu en lui
mettant des coups de boutoir comme ça
qui peut à un moment donné gaffes et
joue un coup en dessous
allait continuer à jouer les bons coups
tempo prévoir ce qu'il fait il est pas
serein you c'est qu'il est bien il est
passeur un maxime il fait peur allez
faut jouer sur l'aura du champion
meilleur tacticien du circuit
bien c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien ça
passe par là ça passe par une grosse
pression
les dés sont jetés de toute façon le
couvert il est servi
a pas fait tous ces efforts pour vour
perdre une nouvelle fois comme ça
quelques encablures
des bas on n'est pas loin
on n'est pas loin on n'est pas loin de
la gagne on en est loin mais on n'est
pas si loin il suffirait d'une étincelle
de mauvais coups pour you mais c'est pas
grave let's go mais bien sûr mais bien
sûr matticks mcfly les mauvais coups
parfois
ils peuvent venir à toi sont tus les
demandes
ils peuvent se trouver tout seul les
mauvais coups
vous dis l'exemple de nayer c'est le
meilleur exemple c'était impossible de
rater ce qui l'a raté
et pourtant le mauvais coup lui est
tombé dessus la connerie n'est jamais
loin
surtout dans ce genre de situations avec
pression maximum
c'est dans ces moments là qu'on voit les
durs qu'on voit l'effort
faut prendre 5 est ce que ce serait pas
un coup de chiottes il faut prendre 5
est ce que ce serait pas un coup de
pleutres
oh mais c'est un coup de plus le train
international ça faut prendre 5 c'est
pour tout échanger et faire drôle
c'est pas possible
oh le coup de pleutres aux gens plus
j'en peux plus le mec joue à annuler un
le mec veut pas aller aux candidats il
s'en fout il a trop peur c'est pas
possible
il veut faire tour de il veut tout est
changé prost pleutre
le coup et mauvais un os le coût est
mauvais qu'est-ce qu'il ait plus de
bordel
oh la la
il vise la nulle quoi ils visent la
nulle il laisse la responsabilité du jeu
à maxime malgré qu'ils soient mieux
qu'il a la responsabilité de la qualif
c'est insupportable
je crois qu'il a fait tout re 2 il veut
tout est changé
c'est pas possible
alors autant faire
l'enfer il veut cavalier a eu quatre
meilleurs coubon logique façon carrier
d'amd 5
le mec joue là nul avec les blancs c'est
infernal
ça dégoûte non mais c'est tellement dur
de gagner une partie pour maxime les
mecs veulent que faire drôle quoi
jamais vu ce à quoi tu joues place aux
candidates et mieux tu joue clairement
gains et maxime te fait tellement peur
de par son aura de par sa puissance de
par son son niveau de jeu
incandescent
que tu envoies a pris soin tout
cavalier ou quatre dames des sacs noirs
mais bon j'ai en bout d'un moment
pourquoi tu viens jouer le tournoi quoi
tu joues une place au candidat frère tu
aies jamais le candidat tirage à mais je
vous le cas maintenant
j'en peux plus quoi pas tour des cinq
pardon dam des cinq jeux chop moi même
le mec joue draw quoi
je peux pas faire un ces sept pour
forcer
pour prendre 4 g dames ces deux quand
même bon leur 10ème pas du tout il y
tour des quatre oui tu vas y changer
quoi tu fais nul mais jouer aux échecs
tu as une chance d'aller aux candidats
apprend là qu'est ce tu fais
maintenant mais en vrai enfin maxime il
ouvre le jeu il prend les risques machin
et tout le mec continue à céret quoi
joue aux échecs
jouer aux échecs
m et voilà manque de f c'est maxime qui
fait peur c'est laura ces machins et il
y prendre aussi bien je peux comprendre
après juste la comté dans le truc
ça dégoûte on n'a pas cavalier e 4 d'un
des cinq dames f6 marlou
temps points 4 au rêve des huit tours
des huit
au nom alors direz fuite at on des
enfants des cinq taureaux huit matchs
à la la la la la la
mais pourquoi t'as pas si fois les
blancs et cinq fois les noirs comme les
autres pour le punir ice bar
c'est insupportable
vous dites car elle des cinq dames des
huit
veaux le shaq qui fait plaisir
aux menaces cavaliers c3 et surtout
prend 1,4 à tour eu des 8 et on prend
des uns au magnifique home est
magnifique le chat oh ça peut se
présenter et dames b3 ahmed un b3 il
veut dame prend b3 c'est prend b3 pour
faire trop il mais tu lui refait tout
dames 5 tu le mets en face au ca
pleutrerie au qui revient d'un des cinq
d'un v8 dame b3 et maintenant on va
jouer
magnifique
ce que je peux dame
à 7
ça va être dur quand même
damas 7 ça va être dur dam des trois
matches angers est ce que je peux tu as
may 8 j'ai deux cavaliers f3 et puis on
prend et j'ai pas le temps de bouffe
bouffe
ok mais qui aura lieu quatre dames des
cinq dames b8 dame b 3 dames 5 tu fais
chantage annulant mais ok mais tu peux
aussi du fait nul avec les blancs tu te
regarde plus dans une glace en fait à un
moment donné ou alors tu vas te voir
dans le miroir quoi c'est pas possible
mesdames
dans le règne de maxime c'est tellement
le stylo à la maison tout reprend 1,4
tour des huit
non mais tu peux pas tu peux pas assumer
la pleutrerie jusqu'au bout en fait je
pense que dame b 8 dans des sacs des
dames dame cinq dames des cinq ans fait
juste tu te regarde plus dans une glace
si tu fais ça tu peux pas
non mais juste tu peux pas faim tu peux
pas tu veux pas sérieusement de regarder
dans une glace si tu fais ça
c'était tellement pleutre si tu fais ça
tu peux pas tu peux pas faire ça tu peux
pas t'as pas le droit
non il n'a pas le droit dans le dessein
que dame des huit dames b3 b5 d'amd 5
n'a pas le droit en fait juste eu peut
pas décemment faire ça
genre même toit par rapport à toi même
en fait c'est pas possible tu te sens
pas bien quoi le car est le cas de jouer
dans mes sacs avec at t sur maxime on
sent qu'il est confiant
alors peut-être alors peut-être les amis
on se remet à rêver et s'y prête que
pouvait mettre un peu de pression
ça pourrait faire du bien
non non tu tries si tu fais d'euros
comme ça tu te respecte pa on tu peux
pas tu te respecte pas
surtout avec la position qu'il avait
mais bien vu le chatt al dante 8 le
dante sinko d'amd 8 mai très très bien
ça empêche les d'euros
non franchement dam des cinq dames des
huit dames b3 tas sur ta sur une
deuxième date à sur une
huitième position en liga en quoi
c'est pas possible
il a fait quoi
[ __ ]
j'ai jamais vu ça
je vous jure ci-après dam des huit dames
b3 dâm sen qui fait d'amd 5
j'hallucine quoi
juste j'hallucine en vrai
parce que vraiment avec caruana dans le
dur une victoire l'on voit vraiment aux
candidats lors de quasi sûr
genre tu peux pas faire ça genre tu peux
pas
il n'y a pas deux mondes
dans le hockey mais dame b 8 dames b3
d'am dam dam je comprends qu'il ya damev
4 et que ça joue mais tu peux pas avoir
envie de faire ça genre décemment ton
idée ça peut pas être d'un v8 dam des
trois dames eu cinq gros t'as pas le
droit t'as pas le droit t'as pas le
droit
il ya personne qui fait ça il ya
personne il y en a qu un bordel qui fait
ça il y en a qu'un
ça juste eu peut pas aller mon max m'a
dit à mme b 8
qui montre son vrai visage à 10 ans voit
mon max
et il était très bien tu peux pas
rentrer en force dans un truc pour
répéter
c'est indécent de faire ça c'est
indécent
sans bluffant ces couacs un petit 2
bluffs
zidane des 8 tu vas l'avoir c'est sûr et
dames b3 d'un f4
mais maxime il va la gagner
ça pourrait être une journée incroyable
ainsi maxime l'a gagné et il va aux
candidats la la la journée les
magnifiques un peut-être la plus belle
journée de ma vie de streaming si ça se
passe comme ça
le stress faut qu'ils les dames dès 8
ans fait d'amd vis de ça à l'air d'être
un joli coup
c'est l'appât
panique là
je pense qu il al dam des 8e d'amd 8 à
une belle tête quand même une fois que
tu l'as vu mais max et son règne de m 6
tours 4 tours des huit il va voir que ça
marche pas il va trouver d'un bep 8 c
sur
peut le faire franchement on a toutes
les chances de notre côté
j'effectue un bluff qui venu pour
bluffer maxime mais il était gagnant ya
pas de bluff c'est juste qu'il a peur en
fait you c'est maxime qui fait très peur
à tout le monde et personne ne vous bien
contre lui mise à part top niveau tout
le monde veut d'euros contre maxime il
fait trop peur et il a trop peur
psychologiquement maxime il est au-dessu
faut qu'ils réussissent à 6 maxime
réussi à trouver delà du jeu ea et à
complexifier cette position ça va
craquer côté à côté ue c'est quasiment
sûr
menace d'un v8 sa menace cas ici trois
échecs
hyper fort
cet opus que les blancs étaient mieux
mais juste y avait beaucoup de jeu et
maxime maxime c'est un joueur que
[Musique]
tout le monde le crée un maxime en fait
parce que ils calculent très bien et il
y en ait note qu' en approche c'est une
partie à pression et maxime c'est un
gros poisson quoi
par le cas maintenant puisque sur
tourcoing katia tour des huit
et on tape
là dedans
mais en fait si où c'est que du craquage
psychologique un sais pas
c'est juste rattrapé par la peur c'est
ça arrive à tout le monde en fait c'est
c'est comme ça
ça rassure tall a pour le moment c'est
maxime qui a le meilleur mental des 2
mai
[Musique]
mais bon il faut avoir une position avec
assez de ressources tactique
c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça c'est il le fait pas
exprès un you
évidemment c'est très frustrant côté
côté français c'est juste dommage de
tomber sur un joueur comme ça quoi la
dernière
dans l' appariement c'est vrai qu'il y
avait beaucoup de joueurs plus facile
notamment aux part in
il a il n'a pas tapé le joueur le plus
faible 1 maxime il a tapé le plus fort
de son groupe après c'est comme ça le
défi est grand plus la victoire est
belle
je pense que le cavalier c3 et sur lui
en prend
pas la gagner en fait il veut la gagner
mais juste il est inquiet et il choque
fins
il a tellement peur de maxime que il
préfère jouer à une position avec 95% de
nuls et 5 % de victoires
une position avec
50% de victoires 20 % des fêtes et
et 30% nul parce qu'ils pensent qu
objectivement si maxime à 20 % de
victoires il est tellement plus fort que
lui que ça va tourner donc en fait il a
un biais cognitif dans son cerveau pour
simplifier parce qu'il a peur et ça lui
fait prendre des mauvaises décisions
mais des mauvaises décisions pour gagner
pour aller aux candidats pas des
mauvaises décisions pour aller faire la
nulle quoi
c'est ça le truc mais ce qui se passe
c'est que s'il a mal jugé un truc et que
maxime réussi à mettre à le mettre en
danger qui doit défendre pour faire nul
il va complètement implosé
fait silviu ne joue que pour nul et qui
doit défendre pour sauver la nulle il va
imploser mentalement et maxime va le
battre donc là l'enjeu c'est de réussir
à
à retourner cette position plus ou moins
de résultats et demi je sais pas et
réussir à la faire tourner on de
résultats pour max et à ce moment là si
ça tourne à de résultats et que max mais
pression ue va complètement craqué il va
imploser
mais là clairement
clairement c'est ce qu'il faut qu'il
trouve maxime
il faut qu'ils réussissent à maintenir
de la vie dans la position surtout pas
un coup comme dame prend des 5
dès 8 heures en cavalier cours des 8 md
80 hors des limites lors des huit thèmes
des huit fou prend jouable
enfin peut-être un peu la jouer on va
peut-être faire dame d un roi deux dames
des cinq échecs double attaque pour ces
cas de force et d'awa cinq rois b3 dame
prend 1,6
jouable très très jouable ça pour you
c'est pas qu'il a aucune ambition j'ai
faim
you il a une ambition c'est d'essayer de
jouer une position pas trop tactique pas
trop ouverte et gagner la finale
mais il peut pas arriver il veut pas il
veut pas jouer trop complexe
pas là nul en fait ça que vous comprenez
pas trop ils cherchent une position il
peut avoir un petit avantage et même si
à grand risque 2 nuls il jouera ligue 1
cherche pas la nuit fait d'un f4 direct
premiers ce serait pas un mal ou de fou
on le malaise for you est ce que il veut
pas sa maxime
à deux il veut ça
surtout reprend et adam c'est un fou
prend direct damas katia damas 2 mai
lors didonne d'alger trois
dames des deux dames c'est cette chute
le génie
il a vu là il là les amis
[ __ ] il là haut c'est sûr qu'il a un
hall frissons
il l'a or je le connais mon marlou
ils aillent là il lie là je connais le
marlou il l'a c'est son règne
c'est son règne du [ __ ] c'est le règne
de maxime c'est le meilleur joueur du
monde dans ses positions là et ça il l'a
c'est sûr qu'il a 100%
0-12 ans maxime il l'a c'est pour ça que
personne ne veut jouer contre lui c'est
nage dorff
il a assez idée là le génie croyais où
il va pas être bien là you il va pas
être bien pas de draw
la lah de ouf il l'a de ouf
ça peut craquer côté hugh est maintenant
sûr dam des quatre dames b8 au le
malaise
au le malaise pour riou ça peut faire
mal on va regarder il tourne il la
[ __ ] je le reconnais au body language
je le connais mon maxime au langage
parfois [ __ ] il là il la regarde et
regardez regardez regardez le il à eau
et c'est sûr qu'il a c'est sûr
c'est évident les amis
je le connais il a c'est sûr c'est sûr
regardez le langage corporel ilaha illa
trop il à 2000% la croix il va rappeler
les bases
non il écrit sur sa feuille il est
insupportable
c'est magnifique regardez maintenant il
va être tout le temps à six et il est en
face de toi il va tout jouer tempo ue
n'est pas bien haut il est pas bien haut
il est pas bien du tout ue ont là il est
vraiment pas bien
ça fait très très mal
j'ai pas gagarine son truc mais ça fait
tellement peur
il est pas bien ue au le pauvre il
pensait mètres maxime sous pression avec
ça turbo d'euros et la sai et commence à
se lever s'asseoir il l'a
mais si fabiano l'a si fabiano la peur
de l'autre côté c'est extraordinaire
on n'est pas bien fabiano oh mais il est
pas bien fabiano royal peillon qui part
en a quatre attention aux familles
attention fabi aussi ça craque là
haut le stress
oui là il à 200 %
à 200 % et la 7e' déchets parce que you
have à voir mais à 200 % il a
c'est le dernier que c'est le dernier
tournoi que je commande dans ce dans cet
endroit là
maxime peut graver dans le marbre ce
live si maxime gagne je me rappellerai
et se qualifier aux candidats toute ma
vie je me rappellerai que de ce jour
très très clairement
[ __ ] les petits regards dans les yeux
oh la la il a posé les bases
il a posé les bases de ouf maxime
il pose les bases
fayez ue il a compris le danger et
maxime soleil s'il sait que l'autre
c'est aussi il sait que l'ofc et il sait
que l'ofc est il en train d'écrire des
trucs de manière invisible sur ce ferry
il repart
il a guetté dans l'oeil pour voir si
l'autre voyait manon il sait que l'autre
à vue et lui dit je sais que tu sais que
tu sais que je sais que tu sais je vais
de cannes frère je me barre c'est
terrible
ça y est il là
il l'a de savoir
ap a failli ou là maintenant mais il
avait pas de base maxime il a vu dans
son regard qu'il avait maintenant il a
changé de position et ça s'est vu qu'ils
avaient qu'il avait commencé à
comprendre l'étendue des dégâts et c'est
maintenant peut-être fou qui va devoir
jouer la drau la position doit encore se
tenir pour you mais là il ya clairement
une passation de pouvoir dans cette
partie
oldham f4
peut trouver les couilles ou encore 1,7
et hop mondial mais ça va craquer à lyon
j'ai envie d'y croire
j'ai envie d'y croire les amis
alors peut-être
avant donnent plus d'oeufs pour les
blancs frérot arrêter de regarder les
ordis regarder les caméras à regarder
les joueurs arrêtez d'avoir les yeux
rivés sur un + 2 1 + 1 c'est pas ça les
échecs les échecs c'est un combat entre
deux hommes ces deux hommes qui sont
face à face et qui c'est qui se mettent
sur la tronche c'est ça les échecs
l'appareil a pas besoin là de voir les
et val-d'or 10 da il se met des coups se
mettre des coups là sur l'échiquier
clairement essais maxima qui a repris le
vide dans le combat ça veut pas dire
qu'il va gagner mais ça veut dire que là
c'est lui qui est en train de taper
c'est ça les échecs
hélas les coûts seiu qui les encaisses
il va falloir qu'il soit fort dans la
tête tu as ayew
c'est dur dans la tête pour you mais il
peut répondre il peut répondre
maxime il a bien répondu quand même il
en a pris la prix 2 3 de 3,2 jamais là
il a répondu lui a mis un petit uppercut
là il est pas bien ue le dam des quatre
le tour d un cavalier c3 mais pas bien
des français 3 tours b 8 3 pour couvrir
damas quatre dames à deux tours prend à
eux deux surtout reprend il ya
d'amsterdam b2 match fou prend deux
dames j'ai trois attaques latour attaque
le pion dam des deux dames c'est cette
menace damas cinq matches
et là c'est déjà fous ces quatre seuls
coûts de leurs dix dames français 4 et
on va rappeler mouvoir on peut jouer
comme ça là on va la jouer ça doit être
trop quand même mesdames n'est que
d'amener quatre dames ces six tours b un
tour c'est 8 ça va jouer ça ça va jouer
des heures ça ça va jouer jusqu'au bout
de la nuit c'est drôle mais ça va ça va
jouer ça va jouer au bout de la nuit et
ça c'était pas prévu pour you il pense
avoir le tour des humains et forcé les
échanges est allé chercher sa pause à
deux résultats
mais a grandi lui samhain très mauvaise
nouvelle
très mauvaise nouvelle
rien n'est fait les amis allez on y
croit déjà si maxime gagne ce sera
tellement beau en termes de performances
mais si fabi père c'est gagné si fabi
perd on y va au bout du bout j'ai cassé
sur l'innovation était sur ma chaîne là
j'aurais repasser la voir passer la
vidéo de l'entraîneur de toulouse là
le couvert il est servi
la pression
c'est pour des moments comme ça qu'on
suit des tournois d'échecs les amis
c'est pour ces moments là qu'on suit
tous ces tournois tout c'est parti
ce serait vraiment l'action shônen du
joueur français
là ce serait vraiment shonen de chez
shawn heins ça peut pas être plus shônen
que ça
ça peut pas
que salah
les caps remplir des grandes choses
maxime dans cette partie nous montre le
visage qu'on attend de lui enfin quel
grand joueur quand même et ça me fait
penser à tous ces gens qui le critiquent
non-stop ça ça m'en fous ça et pas de
mental et machin est tout à les y allez
allez allez on voyait des partis comme
ça allez-y allait envoyer des partis
comme ça dans les moments les plus
importants vous sortir les doigts comme
ça après la déception d'hier
avec avec tout contre lui les noirs dans
les mauvais truc pas la réussite rien
allez allez encore sortir des partis
comme ça à la 11e ronde allez on voyait
ça c'est impressionnant ce qu'il est en
train de faire c'est vraiment un grand
bonhomme maxime les forêts pour une fois
ça tourne en sa faveur
parce que là il y donne toi il donne
vraiment tout
donne vraiment où maxime
peut il fait la partie absolument
parfaite
c'est magnifique
c'est magnifique ce qui fait
c'est incroyable la partie est juste
incroyable et fabiano de l'autre côté
qui est en train d'être chaude peut-être
bien plus en plus là non pour pour lui
il ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
dans sa tête parce que il ya
trois-quatre coup il a pris la décision
de rentrer dans une position simple à de
résultat qu'un nul
et pour ça il a sacrifié une grande
partie de son avantage et là il vient de
perdre tout son avantage et il se
retrouve dans une position à 3 résultat
est là c'est très très difficile dans la
tête pour yuma fort que ce soit un très
très grand bonhomme pour pour la tenir
ici à lyon guy ça a été un joueur du top
mondial il était top 11 c'est un grand
joueur guillon guy faut pas sous-estimer
l'adversaire mais très très clairement
il va falloir qu'il soit très très fort
là le joueur chinois
pour y aller
et + 13 minutes il reste dix coups
continuent à réfléchir frérot si maxime
du plantain pièges vicieux dont il a le
secret au cou 36 quand il restera une 30
ayew il peut tomber pieds et poings liés
dedans
j'ai envie d'y croire j'ai envie d'y
croire
envie d'y croire au doublé français 1 2
les mains moites huawei mains moites
très clairement
l'attention népal l'un
des trois ça ferait plaisir aux phobies
trois ce serait magnifique coucher de
aussi accueilli ces trois magnifiques
il faut bien s il faut qu'ils jouent
tempo
après il faut qu'il joue blême peau il
faut jouer vite et bien là il ya plus de
conseils à donner mais s'il a le coup de
fouet que c'est le coup qu'il avait
prévu et qu'ils envoient tempo ça va
faire très très mal mais
hélas après c'est dur de prendre la
bonne décision ça s'ajoute joue dans la
tête ça se joue à la res ça joue plus
rien si on est dans l'irrationnel là les
amis on est dans l'irrationnel
uyar in the irrationnelles comme disent
nos amis
anglophones
là on y est vraiment
là il ya plus des y'a plus rien il ya
l'orage punch et moi
on est on est dans un autre monde là en
est hors de l'espace temps
la vérité de cette partie ya que les
deux joueurs qui la détiennent les dés
sont jetés le destin est écrit roi ça
sent le coup de chiottes ça sent le choc
je vais être obligé de regarder la tv
l'instant parce que je peux plus analysé
roy ça sent le coup de chott
la turbie ne s'affole pas
malheureusement
malheureusement là turbine s'affole pas
le coût est solide
j'espérais que ce soit un coût de shot
mais non première ligne
ou très solide de yu
c'est un grand joueur dans les grands
moments
il joue l'acier
va fort le faire craquer
ça aurait pu être un mauvais coup parce
que ça peut donner des dames c'est un
dans leur âge ou des dames à quatre
effets il reste encore tout à faire dans
cette partie
pour ces cinq chances le problème ces
dames français 5 qui avait passé cinq
tours prend huit
matches mais peut-être tour e5 est
jouable haye adam des huit tours 8 non
ça non
peut-être et 5
à ces coups de petites turbines propose
justice où j'ai cinq
g5 vu la situation ça donne plus envie
g5 c'est pour avoir tout retour 5 ou
tour c5 est plus ferme à thé du couloir
ça a l'air d'être un coup intéressant g5
peut y arriver on n'est pas loin c'est
pas loin de céder côté hugh maxime qui
veut essayer de jouer vite mettre la
pression
si la g5 c'est très très fort mais moi
j'ai pas j'ai pas grosse turbine la
petite turbine hésite entre g6 et g5
mais vu de l'extérieur on must win comme
ça je serais tentée par g5 mais tu peux
aussi être temps départ j'ai six pour
pour bloquer les cases blanches
les fraîchement nommé les pendules sont
et fraîche non
non les points de vue elle bégaie
il a joué j'ai si c'est ok j'ai si c'est
bien aussi
j'ai si c'est bien aussi
pour des vins on fait quoi
qui ont fait tourner ses cinq
médailles france 5 et france et 5 tours
prend 8 3 ou 7
ça doit être proche de nul
mais ce qu'il peut y avoir un piège
mais faire ça les change trop
ce qu'il ya un jeff
ne crois pas
le couple logique hein ça cloud mais
juge me demande si en jeff
s'il ya un petit piège
cinquième à tours 1 c'est quoi la diff
pour 5 ha et surtout prend 1,4 printemps
reprend qui comprend en plus j'aurais
fait g5 se stabiliser les pièces
entre g6 et j'ai cinq membres à turbine
est à l'aller pas du tout assez forte
pour voir sedif là
mais j'ai pas g5 j'avais un bon feeling
mais c'était pour bloquer protéger
g55
dimpre emprise kg 3
ça doit être drôle
la position après j'ai 6
il a fais toi
c'est sympa de nous en fait ça
c'est sûr qu'il aurait pour ça que
c'était le coup qui m'inquiétait
il veut vraiment faire drôle en fait
avec les blancs c'est cette arrivée fait
tout pour faire un nul en fait
il fait tout pour faire annuler
le tout échanger faire annuler ouais
c'est vraiment pas de bol pour maxime
weil contre un gars qui veut d'euros
dont 5 pour créer le déséquilibre en
fait ce sera peut-être même mieux pour
les blancs ça le problème
c'est quand même deux tours un fou même
content dame cavaliers ça va jamais
gagné
impressionnant
c'est un ex gendarme dans les tours
c'est ça qui va un stand reprendre
prendre 8 et faire drôle
je pense qu'il va la jouer il a fait
tour c5
ça va échanger il va essayer de tourner
avec la lame et lecavalier
après l'aurait fait
et pas eu tour il y aurait d'un médecin
qu'il y aurait eu échange aussi
aller
ouais
pas comment ce genre de positions qui
sont quasiment un prêt sable en vrai
5e 5 tours 8 c'est dommage
va nulle part de quelques grands prix
maxime il est déjà qualifié
jussi var en grand prix il a beaucoup
moins de faim il est à plus de 50 il
gagne cette partie va au candidat il
fait nul au grand prix ses chances sont
très limitées de gagner un il y aura
tout le monde au grand prix
là il gagne la position à plus de 50 il
a 50 % de chances de gagner il joue le
gari la gagne il est aux candidats
spa c'est tellement proches
après on peut être mécontent de la
manière
dont le chinois à jouer mais c'est son
droit le plus fondamental
sa part l'encontre des règles il a droit
de jouer la drau 1
c'est comme ça le mec veut pas le
candidat et veut pas y aller un
si tu veux y faire pas obligé
d'avoir envie de gagner un
cas c'est la bonne nouvelle pour fabiano
ça
caruana
ça peu drôle je sais pas
hockey maxime a encore un tour 3 c'était
cool plus pleutre ce que j'avais prévu
c'est à dire suivant ce qui se passe il
a encore dû dame b 4 car elle est à 4
dave max
c'est quand même peur ici maxime venus
et aux paris nous prêts que keaven
candidat sera incroyable ça
simple
c'est pas cette année à quatre
précédents les dames des quatre mais à
vrai dire
il n'y a plus assez de vie quoi
il va tenter un effet dam des cats il va
la jouer encore maximin c'est sûr
ok la petite chance de maxime sait
peut-être que ue va essayer de jouer le
ghana aussi finalement
il peut être instable psychologiquement
et décidé de jouer le gain de son côté
ça serait magnifique
d'accord jouir est
il reste pas coup parce qu'il a joué il
a joué ses trois
gt pages sera la position de fabi et là
je crois bien
ah ouais maxime il peut aussi faire la
réponse du berger à la bergère bergère
un
jeu pas sûr qu'ils jouent le gain du
tout maximis il est peut-être pas
vraiment mieux 1
il peut faire une proposition de nuls
tacite et voir si l'autre force le gain
est en train de réfléchir il va faire
tomber 3 c'était l'idée de tours 3
maxime faire payer ces cinq silos de
fées tour 3 avec c'est un pleutre ultime
on n'y peut rien coiffera ça dégoûte
il voit tout ouais il est vraiment mode
en mode draw quoi il est pas eu tous en
mode victoire
tous
mais max en fait il peut pas non plus
s'amuse rsa max en fait non il propose
la répétition il y a eu le ok f1 toi
aussi tu dois gagner maxime en a marre
de prendre la responsabilité de la
partie
me dois le forcer à se découvrir c'est
sûr
il a raison maxime en fait ce truc c'est
qu'à force de prendre la responsabilité
de la partie là aucune chance de la
gagner il finira par la perdre vous à un
moment l'ôter gagnant depuis de faim
était gagnant il était mieux la
cie consolide c'est lui qui va être
mieux aussi avec les blancs maxime il a
raison il lui dit prends tes
responsabilités garçons
car au bout d'un moment tu peux pas de
vita mais ternes âmes
ont la responsabilité du jeu avec avec
les noirs 1
est obligé 1
il a raison maxime la cee et un tu veux
pas le candidat n'y va pas frères mais
on n'ira pas tous les deux ans on coule
ensemble un là au bout d'un moment
aucun mais l'autre a aucun intérêt non
plus donc tu joues au coin écoute tu
veux nullement grand garçon était
gagnante a voulu nul à vannes il prend
là maintenant
brésil montre aux yeux de la terre
entière que tu voulais que faire nul
dans un must win à
la raison maxime il le met en face de
ses responsabilités 1 il a tout donné
pour gagner maintenant
vas-y frère
c'est une ans il a raison maximin
qu'es tu vas pas tu vas pas lui faire
cadeau du pount on a déjà beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup fait avec les noirs tu
as laissé l'avantagé à ma feinte a tout
fait pour pousser tant lb cac le machin
l'auteur joue la répétition à l'hérésie
prends ta nul
effet ton tour aux trois qui a avalé
acaata aie fait tour à 3 et wii vas-y
cavaillac as-tu veulent annuler vas-y
prend là un
vase imax influent qui a valu à quatre
temps qui veulent annuler il aura
su y faire vraiment
beaucoup on y rit jouer un
vrai cavalier à 4 il veut vraiment tour
b3 en plus c'est tombé 3 seul coup
a bloqué au bout d'un moment
ce que tu peux y faire en fait
le mec 30,0 responsabilité de la partie
tu lui donnes tout tu donnes la gabegie
tu lui donnes la cb il veut il prend
même pas l'eau dit quoi
tant pis tant pis 1
je vais faire mais ne veut pas jouer il
veut pas gagner vas-y car il ya 4 max
balech a bien joué bien joué et max il a
raison de faire ça maxime
j'en peux plus il fait tomber tempo
oui on a marre y en a marre
il y en a marre
il veut nul
mais maxime chance qu ils obligés de
prendre sinon il va perdre à fort à
force
maxime qui cela elle va voir fabiano il
sait qui venu il sait que s'il gagne
comme fabiano va pas gagner qu'il a une
meilleure des partages il va au candidat
tu peux rien faire
tu ne peut absolument rien faire
j'avais dit que hugh c'était un bon
apparemment parce qu'il jouerait ligue 1
comme il peut alors candidat mais maxime
lui ai dit ok
c'est toi qui a le meilleur des partages
c'est toi qui as les blancs c'est toi
qui peux jouer de bien aussi en fait
pour jouer le gars il faut être deux la
cia que maxime qui joue bien il va se
faire contrer faut qu on prenne des
risques
ça m'a dégoûté
ça dégoûte
tour à 3 tempo il en a rien à faire
[Musique]
c'est son droit c'est son droit il joue
la psychologie aussi dit à maxime mois
les candidats j'en ai rien à faire de
façon je suis mauvais je gagnerai pas
maxime il joue khayat et tour des trois
c'est nul
je suis dit
si tu veux pas y aller
ami
maxime a ouvert le jeu maxime a tout
donné et maxime a poussé la chance
sourit aux audacieux maxime était
audacieux il aurait il fallait jouer en
arrière à la dernière
pas de bol
pas de bol eu
ue il a fait sa partie n'a pas pris de
risque et il a voulu vraiment jouer il
est parti avec la philosophie joue
foudre au
pied il a pris peur il a ouvert le jeu
dans l'ouverture et après il a pris peur
faut respecter faut respecter les
décisions des joueurs c'est comme ça
évidemment quand on est supporters
c'est dur
quand on est supporters c'est difficile
mais c'est le droit de lyon guy de faire
ça
il veut pas prendre de risque il est
moins fort il fait la serrure et il
prend là nul
c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça on n'y peut rien
c'est tout à fait tout à fait son droit
il prend
prend une place évidemment et beaucoup
de frustration un côté français et c'est
aussi compréhensible mais mais c'est le
sport on peut pas forcer quelqu'un à
jouer les gains même s'il en a un
intérêt
à considérer
qui pouvait pas battre maxime à la
régulière
et voilà c'est comme ça
c'est la déception c'est comme ça
voulu risquer après
de toute façon à ce qu il peut aussi
rassuré c'est que fabiano il est plus
perdants seraient pas changé grand chose
on n'y peut rien on n'est pas un
maxime il fait peur en fait c'est ça le
truc il mieux il aurait sûrement jouer
la gagne jusqu'au bout contre d'autres
quoi
on est si les très bons tactique et il
vous a voulu jouer l'assurance et après
du coup il a raté sa chance il a pris là
nul ça se comprend en vrai
oui six fois en blanc à m c'est un grand
avantage une fois plus les blancs
après maxime aurait peut-être dû pousser
comme ça contre sa chique hirian ce
serait peut-être plus passer après avec
des si on coupe du bois
c'est comme ça
un may ou en fait il a tilté dans sa
tête ça arrive il a juste choquant fait
suer y faire il ne fait pas exprès de
pas gagné
il ne fait pas exprès
c'est juste un maxime fait peur
jusqu'à une défaite s'il gagne quoi
faire ça mais c'est pas rationnel en
fait ce qu'il a fait
you say pas rationnel
c'est pas rationnel qui s'est passé dans
sa tête ayew c'est la peur le stress et
du coup tu prends les mauvaises
décisions et à prêter plus en contrôle
c'est comme ça
maintenant je pense qu'il faut plutôt
espérer
une nulle de fabiano et une qualif de
fabiano candidats où on n'aura pas dans
les pattes au grand prix
mais hugh c'est un joueur solide il est
réputé pour être très solide s'inquiéter
un peu
ga après quatre heures de jeu non pas
des décisions rationnelles c'est ça
faby ça va passer je crois que ça va
même passer quasi sûr
je pense que ça va être quasi sur
les tchèques les autres résultats mais
visuellement nul le qualifie et là y'a
plus de lits à la tour qui viendront des
c'est comme ça
salo barinas cet ennemi
mais je crois qu au départage il est
tellement bien
faby chevalet tchèque
mon pari ni les larguer au départage
km heure il était loin aussi landreau
draw qualifie fabiano c'est sûr
il ya un très mauvais départage
non nul de fabiano lui assura la qualif
de fabiano assura sur sa qualif donc ce
sera sûrement les deux
ce conte sûrement sûrement fabiano
alireza finalement c'est quand même les
meilleurs qui se qualifie en pas de
plots
on à vivre la tension est redescendue
ray
c'est le sport c'est comme ça
savoir féliciter aussi l'adversaire et
les adversaires qui
font leur parti
ouais
ouais on a passé un bon mois avant un
petit peu vibrer un
sourire à la coupe d'europe par équipes
à maui dès la semaine prochaine
une prochaine
petite pub qui parent
un super tournoi a pratiquement jamais
été mal aimé ça suffit pas il fallait il
fallait le petit truc en plus
l'intérêt qu'il a raté une chance de
gain et que comme il a raté beaucoup de
chance hier il n'a pas voulu prendre de
risques et il pense que caruana est bien
meilleure ah c'est ça ouais
il a raté sa chance parce que
psychologiquement
il a craqué en fait et du coup après la
décision de faire nul fait il a craqué
dans la tête
il a craqué dans la tête ue
c'est comme ça ça arrive hein
ali reza qui est qualifié ça c'était la
bonne nouvelle de début de journée
par les envois non non il a craqué dans
la taille ou à un autre jour un autre
moment un autre joueur en face ils
auraient pas fait ça il a craqué dans la
tête
souffrant
deux medley chances de gains avec et à
plus de plus de plus de 50 sur l'ordi
quand même
mais il a complètement il s'est hissé
écroulé dans la tête
bien sûr c'est rassurant de tournoi à ce
qu'il y ait eu avec fable sur les partis
tous les jours merci à toi raymond
d'avoir suivi
j'ai prévu la qualif à cet ennemi et il
fallait qu'on vient du coup
fallait s'atténue ce qu'en fait je pense
pas en terme de points cette fois je
passe ans je pense en terme d'écart
mais c'est cet ennemi
s'atténue j'avais dit départage huit
premiers premier sur
sans se faire un petit débrief demain
soir
j'ai pas vu le cas ici trois à près d'un
mètre 4 au début mais
en fait ça s'est vu qu'il avait pas vu
et ça s'est vu au moment où il a vu le
ph ce que je disais quand on regardait
les calmes il ya un moment ça c'est vu
qu'il avait vu et maximise s'élever
direct
il a ça s'est vu au moment où il a vu on
l'a vu les gens de l'est fabien olicard
machin et le tchad genre en mode vous
commenter n'importe quoi mais ça s'est
vu ça se confirme comme souvent
vous voulez suivre la fin de la partie
celle là
et en vrai
ça il prend la drau fabiano enfin bien
nos candidats
il a fait fou prend b2 b5 tout reprend
b5 puis on prend b2 temps prend b2 tour
prend 1,5 bref 2 il le sait fabiano que
l'annulant voix au candidat on va
regarder on va on va regarder parce que
ça va se terminer maintenant
ouais je prends à 3 et ça c'est
complètement nul on peut une première on
va voir si ça fait nul tout de suite
mais à
mais ça c'est comme si c'était nul
fabiano dès que maxime
ayons fait on fait nul il prend là nul
donc pas de regret pour maxime l'annuler
signé fabiano caruana sera au candidat
les amis
fabiano caruana sera au candidat bon je
pense qu' aucun regret que pour maxime
parce que dans la position où il était
là nul était assurée on verra le
départage ce soir mais je pense qu'il
aura aucun regret
bien joué bravo
bravo fabiano qui mérite il a faim et
demi sur deux contres les deux autres
stars en forme du tournoi firoud déjà et
mvl il était fatigué aujourd'hui l'avait
pu il n'y avait plus énergie là tout
donné dans les trois dernières parties
oui s'est arrachée et ils passent de
justesse fabiano et ça fait plaisir de
le voir
qualifier aux candidats le joueur
italien
ça fait plaisir de le voir y retourner
parce que parce qu'ils méritent un il a
tout donné
ça fait ça fait plaisir pour fabi
qui méritent vraiment sûr voilà pour son
niveau de jeu global
pour ce qu'il apporte aux échecs pour
toutes les idées dans les ouvertures qui
la porte parce que parce qu'un fabi en
grande forme c'est clairement numéro
deux mondial et ça peut venir titiller l
2 le numéro 1 et cette qualification au
candidat va peut-être lui remettre un
boost en tout cas il est venu à ce
tournoi il avait très mal commencé le
champion des états unis championnats des
états unis il avait réussi à retrouver
sa forme sur la fin il a très mal
démarré ce tournoi et il a réussi à
aller chercher une victoire au bout de
la nuit contre grande et luce il bat
firoud déjà ils annulent avec les noirs
maxime qui a sorti une grosse game et il
assure sa place aujourd'hui
belle performance du joueur américain
ça fait ça fait quand même plaisir de le
voir qualifier nous on a déjà firoud
déjà on a un français donc on peut on
peut aussi être être content de ce
résultat globalement forcément déçu pour
maxime mai mais au moins la place est
laissée à quelqu'un qui clairement sur
son niveau de jeu global mérite
amplement d'être aux candidats et des
candidats sans fabiano serait aussi
aussi été triste
donc ouais voilà magnifique magnifique
pour
pour le joueur
de la botte le joueur italien
qui sera reconduit a plus un adversaire
de maxime pour les grands prix fier dé
vue la forme qu'il a en ce moment c'est
pas non plus une mauvaise nouvelle
il mérite
deux européens et ouais deux européens
dans ce tournoi place aux candidats et
dubaï
et duda cardiaque est une quatre joueurs
européens
bravo
bravo à famille énorme joueur
combien de
parmi parents gp fidelio de nouveau deux
places plus qu'une puisque bas qui vont
prendre une 1
5 les parents du championnat du monde
est c'est un tir groupé un des joueurs
européens pour le moment
il ya une chance problèmes réels de se
qualifier dans un abattoir ouais c'est
ça il y aura un dernier circuit avec
deux places
au mais déjà un français qualifiés c'est
quand même faut rester sur le positif 1
faut rester sur du positif juste on a
vibré jusqu'au bout et on espérait
vraiment pour maxime disqualifie 1
philou là pour comprendre les grands
prix fidh il faut être bac +4 en
compréhension de tournois
de la fidh donc je ne m'exprimerai pas
là dessus dans c'est un peu compliqué il
ya trois tournois tu peux jouer que deux
sur trois donc c'est complètement déjà
pas équitable parce que tu vas pas jouer
les mêmes joueurs et si tu joues le ton
est numéro 3 était avantagé parce que tu
auras des joueurs qui sont déjà éliminés
donc il ya zéro équité dans le tournoi
et après il ya des phases de groupes
étouffant c'est un truc c c'est encore
encore une usine à gaz compliqué
c'est sain csp ça le truc c'est qu'il ya
trois tournois qui donne des points mais
tu peux en jouer que deux sur trois dont
suivant les deux tournois que tu joues
par rapport aux adversaires au machin au
groupe haug a déjà éliminé tu peux être
clairement avantagés il n'y a pas
vraiment d'équité sportive dans le dans
le format n'ont même pas du tout parce
que c'est comme si on faisait un grand
prix de formule 1 il ya des grands prix
tu fait d'autre que tu fais pas sur un
championnat du monde avec des
adversaires qui les jouent pas tous non
plus donc c'est du grand n'importe quoi
il ya eu trois france au collège quand
même eu jamais eu deux
pas d'excès
grand suisse de toute façon tout le
monde savait que ce serait une loterie 1
après on voit que c'est quand même les
meilleurs qui vont au bout 1
écoutez les gars sur ce mois je vais
partir me reposer la semaine a été
longue on fera un dernier résumé demain
dans la journée avec fab
et on fera un petit des briques du
tournoi demain soir
en de spillé moi j'aurai mon
déménagement comme ça mardi je vais
pouvoir un petit peu récupéré histoire
d'avoir de l'énergie demain merci à tous
d'avoir suivi et je vous dis à très
bientôt ciao tout le monde merci encore
assez une bonne une agréable fin de deux
week-ends je retiens tout le monde merci
encore